110, die Datenpolizei.
Ich bin gespannt, was ihr da sehen könnt. Passendes Thema haben wir uns dazu auch ausgesucht. Der Titel lautet Fighting the War, eine Bestandsaufnahme. Das Ganze hat einen Hintergrund, den wollen wir auch gleich zu Beginn mal einläuten. Der Hintergrund ist ein Vortrag, den Frank und Rob gehalten haben.
Ich sage vielleicht gerade mal, wer hier ist, weil es sind sehr viele Stimmen heute zu hören. Frank, guten Abend Frank. Peter, hallo Peter. Pavel. Kommt von hinten. Und Tim. Genau. Nur der Vollständigkeit halber.
Wäre ich jetzt auch noch zugekommen, aber macht ja nichts. Willst du weitermachen?
Kann ich machen, ja. Das hing zusammen mit einem Vortrag, den Frank und Rob gehalten haben auf dem letzten Kongress. Den wir am Telefon haben, den Rob übrigens.
Genau, wenn wir uns vorstellen, dann auch alle vorstellen. Hallo Rob.
Hallo da.
Genau, also wir haben heute eine extrem volle Runde. Und ja, Frank und Rob haben diesen Vortrag gehalten, der hieß We Lost The War. Da gab es auch noch einen entsprechenden Artikel in der Datenschleuder dazu, der mehr oder weniger zeitgleich erschienen ist. Und dort wurde halt von vielen Leuten zunächst einmal als recht pessimistischer Blick gesehen, einfach resümiert, dass der Kampf gegen die Bösen verloren gegangen ist. Wir haben in den letzten Jahren einfach viele Gesetze gesehen und viele politische Initiativen gesehen, die einfach in eine Richtung gehen, die uns überhaupt nicht passen. Von der Überwachung der Bevölkerung und der Durchdringung der Telekommunikation durch den Staat und andere, der Verlust der Privatsphäre und viele andere Aspekte auch noch. Und das ist das, was wir heute hier im Dialog noch mal betrachten wollen, auch im Hinblick auf das Feedback, was wir danach bekommen haben, weil das war dann sehr intensiv, es war ein Extrem. Ja, war so ein richtiges Highlight auf dem letzten Kongress. Das war ganz deutlich zu merken. Ja, und ich würde sagen, wir fangen auch mal damit an, erst mal so ein bisschen zu rekapitulieren, was so die Grundthesen waren. Und das macht am besten mal der Frank.
Der Grund für diesen Vortrag war, dass wir festgestellt haben, all die Dinge, vor denen wir immer gewarnt haben, wo wir gesagt haben, okay, das führt in den Überwachungsstaat, das führt dahin, dass die Firmen zu viel Macht über den Einzelnen bekommen, dahin, dass die Entfaltung der Persönlichkeit des Einzelnen nicht mehr vollständig möglich sein wird, weil er nicht mehr frei handeln kann. All diese Dinge sehen wir jetzt tatsächlich in der Realität kommen. Wir sehen eine Gesellschaft, wo wir uns zukommen, in der das Handeln des Einzelnen in immer kleinteiligeren Mengen überwacht werden kann und wo es auch tatsächlich Folgen hat, die für den Einzelnen irgendwann nicht mehr überschaubar sind. Und der Grund für uns zu sagen, okay, wir haben da wohl einfach mal vielleicht ein paar Schlachten gewonnen, wir haben halt irgendwie die Sachen mit dem Datenschutz an einigen Stellen vorantreiben können, wir haben dafür sorgen können, dass die Kryptodebatte halt nicht schiefgegangen ist und wir immer noch verschlüsseln können. Aber prinzipiell ist es so, dass die Technologiewellen, die da auf uns zurollen, sei es mit Kamerasystemen, sei es mit automatisierter Telefonüberwachung, mit Data-Mining und so weiter und so fort, RFID, all diese ganzen Dinge, dass die uns tatsächlich in eine Gesellschaft bringen, wo wir uns genau überlegen müssen, wogegen können wir uns eigentlich noch wehren, was sind die Punkte, wo wir ansetzen müssen, um die Freiheit zu erhalten, die wir noch haben, oder zu versuchen, auch Szenarien möglich zu machen in der Zukunft, wo wir tatsächlich wieder auch die Sachen ein bisschen zurückrollen können.
Der Versuch, die Freiheit zu erhalten, die wir haben, das ist doch eigentlich das, was du gerade als mehr oder minder gescheitert erklärst, oder nicht?
Ja, weil wir versuchen uns ja tatsächlich immer der Illusion hinzugeben, zu sagen, okay, wir können dann auf der politischen Ebene bewegen, oder wir können irgendwie die Massen überzeugen, oder wir können den Leuten klar machen, dass es da irgendwie Dinge gibt, auf die sie halt achten müssen. Aber letzten Endes ist es weitestgehend gescheitert, wenn wir mal tatsächlich ehrlich sind. Also das heißt, wir bewegen uns in einer Elite-Diskussion. Wir haben in relativ geringem Umfang es geschafft, tatsächlich die politische Debatte zu besetzen, sondern die wird halt von diesen sogenannten Sicherheitspolitikern beherrscht. Und deswegen fanden wir es an der Zeit, halt mal eine Bestandsaufnahme zu machen und zu sagen, okay, wo stehen wir, wo geht die Reise hin, wenn wir uns einfach mal angucken, welche Technologien sehen wir am Horizont, so ähnlich, wie wir als die Internetwelle losging, ungefähr sehen könnten, wo die Reise hingeht, können wir eigentlich heute auch sagen, wohin geht die Reise zumindest auf der Technologie Seite, was folgt daraus für die Gesellschaft und was folgt denn daraus für uns. Um diese Diskussion anzustoßen, haben wir diesen doch etwas, vielleicht vom Tenor her etwas pessimistischen Vortrag gemacht und diesen Darstellerartikel geschrieben, um halt einfach diese Diskussion in Gang zu kriegen, die Leute so ein bisschen aus ihrer Liturgie rauszubekommen, einfach mal klatschen, so jetzt ist die Zeit, jetzt mal genau nachzudenken, was können wir noch tun, wo müssen wir unsere Energie fokussieren, was ist tatsächlich noch möglich?
Also, Rob, bist du noch da?
Ich bin noch da, ja.
Ja, also wenn du möchtest, kannst du dem natürlich jetzt auch noch was hinzufügen.
Naja, was für mich halt besonders wichtig war, ist, wir haben immer oder zumindest ich hab immer gesagt, es gibt da so eine Singularity. Es gibt, wir müssen, hab ich immer gesagt, wir müssen vorbeugen, dass alle diese Technologie gebaut wird, weil deren Nutzen können wir nicht vorbeugen. Wir können nicht dafür sorgen, dass Regierungen nicht, wenn die Technologie schon da ist, anfangen, das zu nutzen und Data-Mining zu machen. Und wenn schon alle Daten, wo wir alle sind und was wir alle machen, und mit wem wir kommunizieren und was wir verschicken und wie viel Geld zahlen, wenn das alles schon in schöne Datenbanken zur Verfügung steht, dann wird das auch genützt werden. Das müssen wir vorbeugen, weil davon gibt es genau keinen Weg mehr zurück. Und jetzt zu sagen, naja, es ist eigentlich kein so wichtiger Moment oder ja, aber wir können doch noch was machen, das wäre dann halt eine Lüge gewesen, was wir alle diese Zeit gesagt haben. Wir haben gesagt, davon gibt es keinen Weg zurück mehr. Das ist ein wichtiger Moment. Das müssen wir versuchen, dafür zu sorgen, dass das nicht passiert. Und jetzt ist es passiert. Da kann keiner mehr mehr irgendwie, da kann keiner mehr nein dazu sagen, das ist passiert und jetzt müssen wir damit umgehen.
Wie?
Ja genau, das ist sozusagen die interessante Frage. Wir haben ja angefangen, diese Betrachtung zu ziehen, ausgehend von der Motivation derer, die diese Technologien jetzt einführen. Also mal zu versuchen, zu überlegen, warum tun die das? Es gibt ja viele Motivationen.
Hast du tatsächlich eine Antwort, die über, weil sie es können, hinausgeht?
Ja.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich habe mal versucht, mich in den Mindset eines 60-jährigen Bürokraten auszudachten, der tatsächlich in einer relativ höhen Position ist, neben dem Beamt des Staatssekretärs, der einfach dafür bezahlt wird, vorauszudenken und zu gucken, wohin geht die Reise, welche Krisen liegen vor uns und was bräuchte so ein Staat aus seiner Sicht, um A seine Macht zu halten und B damit umzugehen. Das kann schon ganz schön deprimierend werden. Wir sehen halt eine Welt, in der die Globalisierung nicht nur die Globalisierung, wie man es immer so nennt, sondern vor allen Dingen die Rationalisierung dazu führt, dass es schlicht nicht mehr Arbeit für alle gibt. Das können Sie jetzt alle aufschreien und sagen, aber wir wollen eine Vollbeschäftigung.
Das ist ja Quatsch.
Es ist schön, dass ihr das wollt. Es wird keine Vollbeschäftigung mehr geben. Der Anteil der Leute, die tatsächlich noch eine sinnvolle Arbeit haben, wird einfach davon abhängen, wie viel Geld der Staat dafür ausgibt, dass Leute noch Arbeit haben. Den Rest der Arbeit werden halt Maschinen tun. Und die immer weitere Verlagerung von sinnvoller Arbeit ins Ausland beziehungsweise die immer weitere Einführung von Mechanisierungsmethoden führt halt auch dazu, dass gerade die ganzen Low-End-Arbeiten halt als allererste automatisiert werden. Es führt halt dazu, dass ein Großteil der Bevölkerung halt einfach auch kein Geld mehr verdient. Die sind halt einfach arm. Und Leute, die arm sind, neigen halt dazu, politisch auch irgendwie etwas nun ja kontrollbedürftig zu sein aus Sicht des Staates. Wir haben das Problem, dass zumindest die europäischen Länder, was ihre Demografie angeht, äußerst ungünstig dastehen. Also Europa ist halt aus kulturellen Gründen keine Einwanderungsgegend. Also die europäischen Länder können offensichtlich mit großen Mengen Immigranten nicht sinnvoll umgehen, wie es zum Beispiel die USA tun können, was halt dazu führt, dass wir halt eine vergreisene Bevölkerung haben. Es wird halt zum Teil aufgefangen durch die Robotisierung und Mechanisierung. Es führt halt dazu, dass es vielleicht uns nicht ganz so hart trifft, dass wir halt irgendwie viele Leute haben, die keine Arbeit haben. Das führt halt auch dazu, dass die Innovationsfähigkeit der europäischen Länder halt absinkt. Dadurch, dass die europäischen Staaten halt kulturelle Schwierigkeiten haben mit Immigrationen, ist halt der Begriff Festung Europa, wird halt dazu führen, dass es halt ernst wird. Also die Grenzen werden abgeschottet, Kontrollen im Inneren werden eingeführt und so weiter und so fort. Wir haben das Problem, dass sich das Klima verändert. Das heißt, dass die Katastrophen wie das Elbehochwasser oder jetzt irgendwie die Schneenummer in Bayern, die werden jetzt jedes Jahr stattfinden. Da müssen wir uns keine Illusionen drüber machen. Das heißt, dass der Staat in seiner Aufgabe als Katastrophenhelfer, als Sicherer, immer wichtiger wird. Also diese Aufgabe des Staates mit quasi militärischen Mitteln tatsächlich das Überleben der Bevölkerung sicherzustellen, wird immer wichtiger, was natürlich auch zu einer Militarisierung, selbst jetzt nicht die Bundeswehr ist, aber eine quasi Militarisierung und Strukturierung der Staatsstrukturen führen wird.
Also militärische Kommandostrukturen letztendlich.
Im Sinne von ja und aber auch davon, es wird halt einfach ökonomisch unglaublich teuer. Es wird halt dazu führen, dass halt bestimmte Gegenden nicht mehr bewohnbar sind, weil du halt da keine Gebäude mehr hinbauen kannst, die du noch versichern kannst. Also sage ich mal, in die Rheinauen an den großen Flüssen und so weiter. Wir gucken auf eine Technologieentwicklung momentan, wo Stichwort Nanotechnologie, Stichwort Biotechnologie, wo es halt auch einfach erhebliche Risiken gibt, die so ein Staat natürlich auch gerne kontrollieren würde, weil es führt halt dazu, dass man halt möglicherweise hohes Konzertechnologien in den Händen von relativ wenigen Leuten konzentriert hat. Und die will man sich natürlich gerne angucken. Also die will man gerne überwacht wissen. Da will man wissen, was tun die so? Die kann man nicht so rumspielen lassen, denkt man sich so. Und das alles führt halt zu so einem Bild der Gesellschaft, das sich halt wandelt von, sagen wir mal einer libertären Gesellschaft, hin zu so einem, naja, Kapitalismus plus Nielke. Das ist halt sozusagen der, also es werden halt sozusagen nur noch die Freiheiten gestattet, die tatsächlich ökonomisch sinnvoll sind. So und das ist aus meiner Sicht ein Großteil der Motivationen, die dahintersteht, dass jetzt diese Werkzeuge auf teilweise flimsigen Begründungen eingeführt werden und dass halt einfach politische Widerstände auch einfach eisenhart gebrochen werden, indem halt ignoriert wird. Da wird halt einfach am Bundestag vorbei die Vorratsdatenspeicherung eingeführt unter irgendwelchen fadenscheinigen Terrorismusargumenten, weil es halt einfach andere Beweggründe dahinter gibt. Und das ist sozusagen so der Szenario, was ich so ein bisschen aufgebaut habe, um mal zu versuchen zu verstehen, warum tun die das eigentlich. Because we can ist natürlich immer ein guter Grund, aber das reicht halt in der Regel halt auch nicht aus. Und die Frage ist, was tun wir da vor diesem Hintergrund? Und einer der wichtigen Punkte ist halt dazu, wir müssen halt alternative Szenarien entwickeln. Wir müssen halt darüber reden, wie kann so eine Gesellschaft aussehen? Wie können wir Technologie zum Positiven nutzen? Und versuchen halt irgendwie, das nicht in so ein Dystopia abgleiten zu lassen.
Aber ist eine Technologie-Debatte ausreichend? Du sagst selber, dass wir irgendwann an einen Punkt gelangen, wo nur noch die Freiheiten gestattet werden, die ökonomisch sinnvoll sind oder ökonomisch wertvoll sind. Das führt natürlich wesentlich weiter als eine Technologie-Frage.
Wir hatten uns ja vorher darüber unterhalten, dass das Ganze im Grunde genommen in die falsche Richtung war, wenn man sich auf die Technologie konzentriert, dass das in Wirklichkeit eine kulturelle oder eine soziale Diskussion ist, die nicht enden darf oder die nicht sozusagen mit dem Zielpunkt... Also es geht sozusagen nicht um technische Probleme, sondern es geht um Probleme, wie wir zusammenleben in unserer Gesellschaft und mit Leuten, auch mit Leuten, die irgendwie herkommen wollen.
Ja und was ich jetzt halt sehe, ist, dass einfach die Einführung von diesen Überwachungstechnologien dazu führt, dass solche Debatten halt schwieriger werden und teilweise auch nicht mehr möglich werden, weil halt Leute, gerade heute, wurden Schauspieler für 48 Stunden festgehalten, weil sie in einem Spielfilm über Guantanamo mitgemacht haben. Ich hab's nur im Vorbeifliegen gesehen, die wurden unter Anti-Terrorist-Gesetzen festgehalten wegen angeblicher Glorifizierung von Terrorismus, weil sie in einem Spielfilm über Guantanamo mitgemacht haben.
Die haben jetzt hier in Berlin den silbernen Bären, glaube ich, bekommen. Von denen sind vier erst mal für eine Stunde dann einkassiert worden, weil sie auf einer Liste stehen.
Weil sie einen Job gemacht haben.
Weil sie auf einer Liste stehen. Und es kursieren ja auch immer mehr und mehr Listen, sodass der Krieg gegen den Terror eigentlich mehr und mehr zum Krieg gegen den Bürger mutiert. Wie man in den USA ist jetzt auch rausgekommen, stehen 350.000 Menschen auf einer Verdachtsliste. Also jetzt müsste man ja, es ist schon erstaunlich, wo jetzt plötzlich 350.000 Terroristen auf einmal offenbar herkommen. Gut, es sind zwar nur Verdächtige, aber es hat halt einfach ungeahnte Folgen und führt auch dazu, dass ich und die meisten, die ich kenne, auch mit größtem Unbehagen nur noch die Vereinigten Staaten bereisen, weil natürlich die Datenbanken in auch so einem schlechten Zustand sind, dass Namensgleichheit mit irgendjemanden, der auf irgendeiner Liste steht, schon dazu führen kann, dass man einfach für mehrere Tage verschwindet. Ich kenne auch Leute, die halt einfach das Pech hatten und dann einfach mal für zwei Tage von der Bildfläche verschwunden waren, weil sie auch kein Englisch sprachen und dann einfach erstmal auf dem Flughafen festgehalten wurden, nicht telefonieren durften. Und ja, das wird also zunehmend unangenehmer.
Wie weit sind wir da in Deutschland?
Es gibt nicht so viele Fälle, aber gerade kam die Diskussion hoch, dass man keine Sozialhilfe bekommt, wenn man auf dieser Terroristenliste steht, dass man keine Grundstücke besitzen darf und so weiter und so fort. Und diese Listen sind halt, also ich hab die mir mal genauer angeguckt, die sind halt einigermaßen lächerlich. Also da sind halt, also Beispiel zum Beispiel die EU-Imbargo-Liste, die halt beschreibt, ob man Güter an diese Personen verkaufen darf. Und zwar so einigermaßen viele Güter. Da stehen halt so Sachen drinnen wie, irgendwas Trading Company am Schreien hinter der Tankstelle in Karachi Pakistan. Das ist so die Genauigkeit des Datensatzes.
Mit denen darf man keine Geschäfte machen.
So. Und wenn die halt irgendwie als Adresse angeben, am Schreien vor der Tankstelle, dann ist das halt ein anderer Datensatz und dann darf man das. Also das ist halt absolut lächerlich, dieser Versuch, irgendwie Terrorismus mit Datenbanken herzuwerden. Aber das führt heute dazu, Peter hatte das auf der Autofahrt vorhin gesagt, dieses Konzept der ewigen Liste, dass man halt sozusagen für seine Handlungen für immer verantwortlich ist.
Das ist, das war das Gespräch ging um die Frage, ob nicht Dinge wie zum Beispiel Resozialisierung oder ein bisschen allgemein ausgedrückt, die die Freiheit, sich zu zu verändern, zu verwandeln, sich weiterzuentwickeln, eingeschränkt wird, wenn wir es zu tun haben mit Technologien, vor allem mit Speichertechnologien, die nicht mehr in der Lage sind, eine sehr wichtige menschliche Eigenschaft umzusetzen, nämlich das Vergessen, das für sowas wie Resozialisierung oder Veränderung einfach unabdingbar notwendig ist.
Einfach das Recht auf Meinungsänderung ist massiv in Gefahr, dass man für etwas, was man vielleicht, ich weiß nicht, mit 17, 18, 19 Jahren mal gesagt hat, dass einem irgendeine Äußerung oder irgendetwas dann faktisch bis an sein Lebensende anhängt und anhaftet und man eben keine Chance bekommt, einfach seine Meinung zu ändern.
Hier ist Chaosradio 110, Helmglumun auf Fritz. Und die Frage, die der CCC sich selbst stellt ist, haben wir eigentlich einen Krieg verloren?
Ja, beziehungsweise...
Den Krieg um die Freiheit, den Krieg für den... Den Krieg um den Teehack.
Aber der Titel war auch Fighting the War und auch auf der Fahrt. Auf der Fahrt hierher, also das ist immer ein schöner Satz, auf der Fahrt hierher, da wird dann immer so einiges klar, so diese letzte halbe Stunde auf dem Weg nach Potsdam. Und dann ist es aufgefallen, dass ja dieser Titel auch so eine Doppeldeutlichkeit hat, weil es ja eigentlich erst mal so gemeint war, mit wie kann man diesen Krieg führen? Aber eigentlich ist es mehr auch, wie kann man eigentlich dieses Krieg führen bekriegen? Weil permanent wird immer ein War gegen was auch immer, gegen Drogen, gegen Terroristen, gegen was auch immer ausgerufen. Und es ist in den meisten Fällen einfach total absurd.
Ja, da gibt es aber ein relativ einfaches Rezept, das hat mein Vater erfunden. Das heißt, kriegt euch alle mal wieder ein bitte.
Ja gut, ich meine, das haben wir häufig genug gesagt, aber das hört sich ja gar nicht an.
Ich wollte einem ja keiner zuholen zu sagen.
Ich wollte vielleicht noch kurz was dazu sagen, dass diese resignative und pessimistische und kulturpessimistische Haltung natürlich auch gefährlich ist. Die erzeugten Menschenbild, das mich erinnert in manchen an so ein Menschenbild, das ist in den 60er Jahren entstanden. Es gab damals ein berühmtes Buch von Vance Packard, das hieß Die stillen Verführer und da ging es darum, dass der Mensch ein knetbares, willenloses Opfer der Medien ist, von der Werbung manipuliert wird, vom Fernsehen und vom Radio zersiebt und durchbohrt und einfach als so ein kleines, dummes, geknechtetes Opfer dasteht. Und dieses Menschenbild, das hat sich wirklich 20 Jahre lang gehalten, bis eine wunderbare, kleine Erfindung irgendwie auf den Plan getreten ist, nämlich die Fernbedienung. Fernsehfernbedienung und plötzlich so diese Selbstbemächtigung begonnen hat und die Leute wieder zu sowas wie Selbstbewusstsein gekommen sind. Und spätestens, als dann das Privatfernsehen eingeführt worden ist und so eine größere Vielfalt in den Medien auch beim Radio irgendwie aufgetreten ist, hat sich herausgestellt, dass das souveräne Nutzer plötzlich ein gefürchtetes Wesen war, der mehr oder weniger selbstständige und schwer kontrollierbare Benutzer mit seiner Fernbedienung in der Hand, der sich wie ein privater Bildmischer irgendwie sah.
Was? Das ist richtiges Optimismus. Eine Fernbedienung als Tool der Freiheit.
Aber wenn du 10.000 Sender hast, dann geht das schon mal.
Ja, das ist ein Ansatz. Es geht ums Menschenbild und um das Selbstgefühl. Es geht darum, dass man irgendwie, man muss mit dem Gefühl anfangen, mit dem Selbstgefühl, dass man sozusagen souverän ist der Technologie gegenüber. Oder das bleiben kann oder das zumindest noch weiter versuchen will.
Wir haben einen Anrufer. Marius aus Braunschweig hat 0331 70 97 110 gewählt.
Grüß Dich. Ja, ich habe da folgende Anregung, beziehungsweise mir ist da so ein paar Sachen aufgefallen. Und zwar ich war mal in London und danach habe ich mal ein bisschen recherchiert, was da so Sache ist. Mir sind ziemlich viele Kameras auch aufgefallen, was die Überwachung dann geht. Also meine Recherche haben wir gegeben, auf 14 Bürger fallen fällt eine Kamera da und das hat alles nichts genützt. Terroranschläge gab es trotzdem.
Was soll die Kamera da auch helfen?
Ja eben und Bewegungsprofile erstellen und so weiter und Überwachung. Das ist ja nicht das einzige, was da so gang gäbe ist. Aber es ist mir halt sehr aufgefallen, wenn man auf den Straßen. Man soll sich sicher fühlen und so weiter. Aber irgendwie, na ja. Noch ein anderes Thema vielleicht. Ich habe irgendwie so ein Vorrausszenario, sage ich mal, für mich. Und zwar, wie sieht das aus, in Zukunft kriege ich hier seinen RFID-Tag bei sich eingenäht unter der Haut und dann wird wirklich das Bewegungsprofil erstellt. Egal was man einkauft, wo man ist, was man tut.
Na ja, wenn es eingenäht unter die Haut würde, dann würde man es ja wenigstens noch mitkriegen, dass es da ist.
Richtig.
Also ich mache mir ja viel größere Sorgen darum, wo das überall drin sein wird, was ich gar nicht mitbekomme.
Das hat ja schon jeder sein Telefon mit dabei. Das reicht schon eigentlich.
Also der Überwachungsstaat wird sich, bzw. das wird ja nicht nur der Staat sein, sondern die Überwachungsgesellschaft, weil die Firmen spielen ja auch mit, wird sich dadurch auszeichnen, dass sie sehr freundlich und unauffällig ist. Das heißt, es wird niemand hingehen und von dir verlangen, dass du dir jetzt so einen Tech unter die Haut schiebst. Es gibt da keinen guten Grund für, wenn du irgendwie tatsächlich dein Telefon bei dir trägst. Und jeder trägt sein Telefon freilich bei sich. Es gibt also, es gibt keinen, also das ist halt genau der Unterschied zum kommunistischen Überwachungsgesellschaft, dass der Zwang wird eigentlich recht selten angewandt werden. Sondern es wird halt im Zweifel halt freiwillige, also es wird so ähnlich sein wie bei der Grenzkontrolle in den USA so. Natürlich können sie ihre Schuhe anbehalten. Hier müssen sie dann halt leider nur etwas intensiver durchsuchen.
Muss da jeder seine Schuhe ausziehen mittlerweile?
Also in den meisten Flughäfen. Das Flughafen abhängig ist. Das ist auch wirklich die Stelle, wo sich die Leute richtig aufregen. Diese Transport Security Administration Beamten sind wirklich der letzte Tractor. Selbst von dem letzten Blue-Color-Worker werden die wirklich als die letzten Ekel behandelt.
In Los Angeles über der Kontrolle am LAX, das war, ich bezeichne es, hängt ein großes Schild, auf dem steht, no jokes please, everything you say is being treated absolutely seriously. Ein großes Schild, no jokes please.
Diese irgendwelche Waffen, aber was brauchst du denn? Kommen Sie mal mit.
Und noch eine andere Sache. Es wurde mir neulich gesagt, im Krieg werden meistens die neuesten Technologien vorangebracht. Also das heißt, wir müssten erst einen Krieg herbeiführen, damit wir technologisch mal wieder einen Schritt nach vorne kommen.
Damit die Teflon-Pfanne mal überarbeitet wird.
Also das ist ja wohl auch ein bisschen abgesorgt, oder? Jetzt müssen ja das Leute draufgehen, damit irgendwie neue Technologien auf den Markt geströmt werden.
Naja, mittlerweile ist es ja nicht mehr ganz so. Zum Glück. Der Technologiefortschritt im zivilen Teil der Gesellschaft hat den im dunklen Teil zumindest in vielen Teilbereichen schon überholt. Und zwar dahin gehend, dass die militärischen Bereiche mittlerweile zum großen Teil zivile Technologie einsetzen, weil die halt noch bezahlbar ist. In einigen Kernbereichen, halt sagen wir mal esoterios Computing zum Beispiel, also Quantencomputing und ähnliche Dinge, ist es schon noch so, dass da halt die Forschung, sag ich mal, im dunklen Bereich vermutlich weiter vorne ist. Und okay, an solche Sachen, die Flugobjekte und ähnliche Dinge. Aber ich sag mal so, dieses prinzipielle Ding, dass es noch einen Krieg braucht, um die Technologie richtig weit nach vorne zu treiben, gilt glaube ich so nicht mehr, denke ich.
Oder? Oder?
Kann man so sagen, ja.
Marius, wir danken für deinen Anruf.
Wir danken, ich danke auch.
Und an dieser Stelle machen wir noch ein bisschen Nachrichten.
Wir müssen leider draußen bleiben. Heißt Sonntag das Motto bei KenFM. Der Grund? Die 250. Show steht an. Ja, KenFM wird fünf Jahre alt. Fünf Jahre, ohne dass wir es geschafft hätten, auch nur einen echten Superstar in die Sendung zu bekommen. Aber lernen wir daraus? Auch diesen Sonntag besuchen uns wieder drei Kombos, die keine Sau kennt. Adwänger aus Österreich, Last Call for Discourse Berlin und Senior Torpedo aus... Zusammen klingen sie so. 5 Jahre KenFM, 250 Wochen, totales Versagen.
Mit wem arbeiten Sie auf der anderen Seite zusammen?
Mit niemandem.
KenFM, immer sonntags von 14 bis 18 Uhr. Live in den Fritz Studios in Potsdam-Babelsberg. Und im Radio.
Vom RBB.
Mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Im Irak droht nach Ansicht seines Präsidenten Talibanie ein Bürgerkrieg. In einer Fernsehansprache appellierte er an seine Landsleute, friedlich zu bleiben. Im ganzen Land war es heute zu blutigen Auseinandersetzungen zwischen Schiiten und Sunniten gekommen. Die Bundesregierung hat die größte Steuererhöhung in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik beschlossen. Kernpunkt ist die Anhebung der Mehrwertsteuer zu Beginn des nächsten Jahres auf 19 Prozent. Etwa 6 Prozent aller Jugendlichen haben Schulden. Das geht aus einer Schufa-Studie hervor. Der Hauptgrund seien nicht etwa die hohen Handykosten, sondern der Kauf von Fast Food heißt es. Die Gewerkschaft Verdi will die Streiks im öffentlichen Dienst in den kommenden Tagen noch ausweiten. Das kündigte der Bundesvorsitzende Bseriske an. Die Beschäftigten wehren sich gegen die geplante Verlängerung der Wochenarbeitszeit auf 40 Stunden. Und noch zum Sport. Das Champions League Spiel Werder Bremen Juventus Thüringen endete für wenigen Sekunden unentschieden mit einem 2 zu 2. In dieser Nacht stark bewölkt, es gibt später Aufheiterung und überwiegend bleibt es trocken. Zum Morgen im Norden etwas Schnee möglich, die Tiefstwerte zwischen minus 2 und minus 5 Grad. Morgen in Uckermark und Prignitz leichter Schneefall, ansonsten Wolken und weitgehend trocken, Höchstwerte 0 bis 2 Grad plus. Mit diversen Meldungen. A2 Magdeburg Richtung Berliner Ring zwischen Wollin und Brandenburg an der Havel. Behinderungen nach einem Unfall rechter Fahrstreifen blockiert. A9 Heideleipzig Richtung Potsdam zwischen Belitz und Belitz-Haltstetten. Behinderungen durch Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Nach einem Unfall ist die linke Spur blockiert. A10 Südlicher Berliner Ring, Schönefelder Kreuz Richtung Spreeau. Zwischen dem Kreuz und der nächsten Anschlussstelle. Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn auf dem Zubringer aus Richtung Spreeau zu A13. A10 Westlicher Berliner Ring, Dreikafelland Richtung Werder. Zwischen Potsdam Nord und Leest gibt es Behinderungen durch Endeffekt des Fahrzeugs auf dem rechten Fahrstreifen. Und frischereingekommen noch die A11, Dreikuckermark Richtung Berliner Ring zwischen Pfingstberg und Joachimstal. Auch hier Gefahr durch Hindernisse auf der Fahrbahn. Und zwar hier auf der linken Spur. Bitte Vorsicht beim Überholen. Ansonsten wünschen wir gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Matthias Kerkov, 22.37 Uhr jetzt.
Und wenn im Radio 102, 6, dann Fritz in Berlin.
Und zwar Chaosradio 110.
Tja, ist eigentlich fast eine gute Nachricht, dass die Kids sich für Fast-Food verschulden.
Ja, nicht wegen hoher Handy-Rechnungen, sondern weil sie sich ekelhaftes Essen bei zweifelhaften amerikanisch-schottischen Burger-Bratereien.
Naja, ich mein, die gute Nachricht ist, das Gammelfleischproblem ist offensichtlich gelöst.
Das ist richtig, ja.
Ja.
Super, in unserem tollen Chat kommen immer gleich so die passenden URLs, das finde ich immer so super, live zur Diskussion. Unter anderem auch die Uhr von diesem Schild, was du gerade erwähnt hast. No jokes, please, sehr hübsch. Kommt auf jeden Fall hier noch auf unsere Seite zur Chaosradio 110 dazu.
Da kann man ja von den Medalisten zuverlässig erkennen, dass sie keinen Humor haben.
Dann müsste man sie eigentlich um Jokes bitten. Bitte machen sie Witze, was ihnen fällt kein Witz ein.
Bärtiger Mann im Kaftan, erzähl einen Witz.
Ich finde das überhaupt nicht lustig, dieses Schild. Weil natürlich Humor, also mal ein paar Witze zu machen, einfach dient dazu, die Spannung aufzulockern. Wenn jetzt einem auch noch das verboten wird, sich da zu entspannen, dann passiert halt so was wie bei der amerikanischen Post. Da sind Witze bestimmt auch verboten. Dieser Effekt Going Postal, wo dann die Leute, ja, irgendwann einfach, weil sie keine Möglichkeit haben, sich abzureagieren, komplett durchdrehen und dann Amok laufen.
Ach, das heißt Going Postal?
Going Postal, weil das ist benannt nach der Serie von Amok Laufen bei der amerikanischen Post. Das passiert halt, also noch mehr als an amerikanischen Schulen, drehen halt Beschäftigte der amerikanischen Post durch und bringen dann in einem Amoklauf ihre Kollegen rum. Das ist, ich glaube schon, etwa 15 oder 20 Mal passiert.
Also ich denke, dass dieses Schild ein sehr guter Hinweis auf eines der Probleme mit dieser Überwachungsgesellschaft ist. Dieses Schild hängt da nämlich, weil die Leute, die tatsächlich diese Überwachungs- oder Grenzkontrollmaßnahmen zu dumm sind, um mit einem Witz umgehen zu können. Das Phänomen ist ja letztendlich, dass in diesen Sicherheitsapparaten, egal ob privat oder behördlich, landet nun mal nicht die cremende Gesellschaft, um es mal ganz diplomatisch zu formulieren.
Du meinst, die bildungsnahen Schichten, die gehen woanders hin?
Genau. Ich weiß nicht, wie man so was im öffentlichen Rundfunk so formuliert.
Also bildungsnah und bildungsfern, das darf sogar die Bundesfamilienministerin benutzen.
Also ich meine, die bildungsfernen Schichten tendieren sich in solchen Jobs zu akkumulieren. Was halt dazu führt, dass genau diese Leute es dann sind, die dann tatsächlich die Regeln entforcen. Und das heißt, dass der Begriff, sagen wir von Ermessensspielraum oder von irgendwie, gucken wir doch mal, was da wirklich passiert ist, der hängt natürlich auch von einer gewissen Bildung und von einer gewissen Art und Weise ab, mit Dingen umzugehen und nicht Schiss davor zu haben, dass man irgendwie eins auf den Kopf bekommt, weil der Vorgesetzte halt irgendwie die Regeln strikt interpretiert sehen wollte.
Ich glaube, es hat nicht so sehr mit Bildung, es hat vielmehr mit dem Wunsch nach Kontrolle zu tun, weil Humor ist sozusagen der Inbegriff des Freiraums und das Gefährliche am Humor ist, dass er immer mehrdeutig oder vieldeutig ist, dass er uneindeutig ist. Und es gibt eben von bestimmten Seiten Interesse, diese Mehrdeutigkeiten, diese Uneindeutigkeiten zu beseitigen und aus welchen Gründen auch immer, also quasi nur noch Eindeutigkeiten zuzulassen und damit eben, genau, bist du für uns oder bist du gegen uns? Genau, und damit aber einfach, damit das, was man im Kern als Freiheit versteht, einzuschränken oder überhaupt auszuräumen.
Aber das ist ja genau das Problem, was Frank auch angesprochen hat. Ich meine, da sitzen nun mal Leute, die für, weiß ich nicht, 4, 50 Euro die Stunde oder sowas, für Sicherheit sorgen sollen, und die sind überhaupt nicht zur Mehrdeutigkeit in der Lage. Und darum werden sie natürlich sich immer brutalstmöglich an die Verordnung halten, die von oben kommt.
So wie die Geschichte von dem geistig etwas verwirrten Passagier, der nun erschossen wurde, weil er von Bord wollte und angeblich was von einer Bombe gesagt haben soll.
Das war dann auch eindeutig.
Hatten wir das mit dem Button schon? Der Button? The Suspected Terrorist? Na, von John Gilmore die Geschichte.
Ja, erzähl doch einfach.
Ja, John Gilmore, auch Hacker alter Schule, der war ja 2003 auf unserem Camp und auf dem Weg nach Deutschland aus den USA, für den über London, soweit ich mich erinnere, hatte er dann so einen Button. Und auf dem Button stand, zack, Suspected Terrorist. Und das hat er sozusagen als politisches Statement aufgefasst. Und dann war es tatsächlich so, das Flugzeug war noch nicht losgeflogen. Dann kam dann irgendwie das Personal auf ihn so und meinte, wir müssten jetzt irgendwie, I'm ordering you to take off that button. Dann meinte er so, nee, mach ich nicht jetzt ein politisches Statement. Ja und dann meinte er so, ja, ich befehle ihnen diesen Button abzunehmen, denn sie gefährden die Sicherheit dieses Flugzeuges und verstößen den Federal Law. Woraufhin er dann auch wirklich aus dem Flugzeug entfernt wurde, so der Flieger ohne ihn startete.
Und seine Frau gleich mit entfernt wurde.
Genau, das auch noch.
Weil sie ihn kannte.
Sie hatte keinen Button, aber sie reiste offenbar mit ihm und wurde dann auch an die Luft gesetzt.
Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die 60er-Jahre, als die ersten Bankomaten aufkamen und es einen Bericht über den Banküberfall gab, wo ein Bankräuber seine Pistole auf den Bankomaten gerichtet hat.
Das Audiosnippet habe ich hier noch irgendwo. Das muss ich mal kurz raussuchen.
Also was wir halt sehen, ist halt, die Einschränkung von persönlicher Freiheit hat halt nicht unbedingt nur mit den expliziten Regeln zu tun, die gemacht werden, sondern tatsächlich mit den impliziten Folgen. Ich kann halt irgendwie mal auch mit meinen Schuhen an, durch irgendwie den Metalldetektor gehen in den USA. Und sehr schön war die Art und Weise, wie dann dieses, da müssten wir sie nur etwas detaillierter untersuchen, ausgesprochen wurde, nämlich mit so einem Schnappen der Gummihandschuhe.
Ab bis zum Ellbogen ist Freundschaft.
Naja, das ist halt sozusagen genau diese angebliche Freiwilligkeit. Ich habe ja zugestimmt. Wenn ich mich da reinbegebe, stimme ich ja zu, mich diesen Prozeduren zu unterwerfen. Ich habe halt keine Optionen, verdammt nochmal, wenn ich fliegen will. Was soll ich denn tun? Soll ich laufen?
Du könntest dir zum Beispiel aus Subversion drei Tage lang die Füße nicht waschen vorher.
Das könnte ich natürlich tun, aber ich fühle hier vielleicht noch ein Flugzeug aus, sind meine armen Mitpassagiere. Also das ist sozusagen dieser Trend, den wir sehen. Dass es halt einfach nicht nur darum geht, dass irgendwie jetzt staatliche Gesetze, wie irgendwie die Abschaffung des Bankgeheimnisses in Deutschland, nur falls noch jemand nicht mitbekommen hat, die Volksbanken und Reifeisenbanken haben irgendwie neulich festgestellt, dass über diese Abfrageschnittstelle zur Kontostandsermittlung ungefähr einmal im Quartal ihr gesamter Kundenbestand abgefragt wird. Das war eine zweistellige Anzahl von Millionen Abfragen pro Quartal, die da stattfindet.
Und haben die auch gesagt, woher die Abfragen kommen könnten?
Von der zuständigen Behörde.
Aber wer ist denn die zuständige Behörde?
Das ist ein Proxy dazwischen. Das heißt, offensichtlich zieht sich da jemand, mal alle Bankkunden so einmal im Quartal. So, das wurde halt eingeführt.
In welchen Ländern war das Bankgeheimnis noch in Ordnung? Österreich war das, oder?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo jetzt gerade noch irgendwie welches gibt, aber zumindest zeigt das halt, wohin die Reise geht. Wenn Überwachungsmethoden und Mittel da sind, dann werden die halt benutzt, ohne weiter mit der Wimper zu zucken. Und wenn man damit halt irgendwie Sozialschmarotzer irgendwie bekämpfen kann, dann werden halt Sozialschmarotzer bekämpft. Und wenn halt mit den Vorratsdatenspeicherungen halt irgendwie falscherer bekämpft werden können, dann werden halt nicht nur Terrorismus bekämpft. Und das ist halt genau dieser schleichende Prozess, der, wenn die Daten einmal da sind, wird es auch benutzt.
Müssen sich denn die Mitarbeiter der BaFin keine Gedanken darüber machen, selbst ins Raster zu fallen oder selbst gerastert zu werden, selbst überwacht zu werden?
Ich glaube, die haben voll das Closure-Pflicht, damit sie nicht bestechlicht sind.
Nee, ich meine, es sind ja auch deren Konten-Daten. Die Mitarbeiter dieser Banken, die haben ja im Zweifelsfall ihre Konten auch bei.
Vermutlich wissen die, wie es geht?
Ach so, das kann natürlich sein. Könnt ihr mal einer anrufen und es erklären? 0331 77 97 110. Der Michael aus Berlin hat genau diese Nummer angerufen, hat eine Frage. Michael? Ja, du hast eine Frage, Michael.
Ich habe kurz vorgespächt, wie oft ihr diskutiert so schön, was uns alles blüht oder was schon in Realität ist. Die USA ist ja auch schon oft genug gefallen, dass es nun eigentlich ein Polizeistaat inzwischen ist. Staatsterroristen, da braucht man nicht lange zu diskutieren drüber. Aber zu dem Thema für Erfitt hat du da auch schon kurz was gesagt.
Ja, das ist deine Frage.
Meint ihr da kurz, wovon Erfitt unter die Haut? Da gibt es nämlich eine US-Firma, die fordert ihre Mitarbeiter in der Tat auf sich, dass er sich schützt, unter die Haut.
Die kriegen dafür so viel Prügel dafür, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass noch irgendeine andere. Firma wagt, genau so etwas zu machen, eher gering ist. Ja, das würde ich jetzt mal so aus dem Bauch schätzen. Abgesehen davon ist halt noch dieses kleine Detail, dass die Erfer, die Chips, die diese Firma ihre Angestellten gezwungen oder freiwillig hat, unter die Haut implementieren lassen. Wiederum ein schönes Beispiel für Freiwilligkeit. Sie dürfen halt sonst nicht arbeiten gehen. Sie sind halt zufällig auch noch gebrochen. Das heißt, die kann man halt problemlos klonen. Das heißt, die haben sich da die Schmerzen umsonst auch nicht angetan. Das ist wirklich ironisch. Na klar, wenn du irgendwie in Branchen arbeitest, wo deine Firma dich zwingen kann, freiwillig dir so einen Tag unter die Haut schieben zu lassen. Naja, da ist die interessante Frage, wie weit denn diese Freiwilligkeit, die Toleranz für diese Art Freiwilligkeit wirklich geht.
Also Michael hat gerade wieder doch eigentlich den Kern des Problems angesprochen, aber wie wird denn anfangen? Das ist rum.
Naja, gut, die kriegen halt ordentlich Prügel dafür.
Die Technologie ist da und es wird gemacht und es wird gedacht.
Sobald wir in den Staaten aus, ich weiß nicht, wie da die Diskussion in den Staaten aussieht. Ich kenne nur die Reaktion hier von Heise online, vom Forum, als da dieser Artikel von dieser Firma, von dieser Aktion da stand.
Also in den Staaten.
Die Reaktion war übrigens heftig, logischerweise, weil die Leute hier dafür nicht so ein Verständnis haben.
Also interessant war die erste Instanz, wo das stattfand. Und zwar war das ein Club in Barcelona, die ihre VIP-Gäste, sozusagen, da konnten... Nee, nee, das war eine Diskothek.
Die haben sogar dafür bezahlt, dass ihr das kriegt.
Genau, die haben irgendwie richtig Geld dafür bezahlt. Und irgendwie alle Technologie-Gagga-Leute aus Europa sind hingeflogen, um ein Nachtclub zu werden und irgendwie sich hier an FAD unter die Haut schieben zu lassen. Und um die Leute sozusagen am Eingang identifizieren zu können und die bezahlen zu lassen. Dieser Club war wohl eher etwas minder positiv überrascht, als ich dann herausstellte, dass genau diese Sorte FAD-Texte, die man hier unter die Haut schoben bekommt, extrem einfach zu klonen sind, weil die sind halt nur einfach Repeater-Texte, die einfach nur eine Nummer schicken. Es ist keine leckere koptografische Sicherheit dabei. Und die sind halt entwickelt worden, um Kühe in Ohrmarken zu markieren. Und Hunde. Und da ist halt die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ein Hund hingeht und seine FAD-Tech fälscht eher gering. So, das ist halt das Sicherheitsniveau, für das das entwickelt wurde. Das ist halt nicht dafür entwickelt worden, dass jemand mal versucht, irgendwie mal seine 5K-Martini irgendwie umsonst zu kriegen. Und das zeigt aber auch wiederum, so Technologie wird halt eingeführt und da wird nicht lange drüber nachgedacht. Und dann fällt sie halt irgendwann auseinander. Aber da kann man sich halt nicht drauf verlassen. Irgendwann funktioniert das halt.
Der zweite Teil meiner Frage, das war ja für ihn immer erst mal so ein Hinweis. Aber der zweite Teil ist natürlich, wie gesagt, man kann viel darüber diskutieren, welche Gefahren drohen, aber wie soll denn eigentlich eurer Meinung nach konkret der Widerstand aussehen? Das ist eigentlich mal die interessante Frage, weil mit Labern ändert man nichts. Und wenn man sich nur die Politiker anschaut, die Konzerne, die scheren sich eigentlich auch herzlich wenig um die bisherigen Formen des Widerstandes.
Wie sieht deine Form des Widerstandes aus?
Ja, ich könnte vieles machen, wenn ich das Geld hätte. Das habe ich aber nicht. Ich habe nicht mal das Geld, um mit BVG oder sonst was für uns zu tun. Ich bin sozusagen aufgebunden.
Tja, also der...
Ich könnte mich nicht mehr in der Sprache in Gruppen verorganisieren.
Was ich denke, ist, dass es zwei Grundlinien, Gebiete gibt, in denen wir in dem Sinne Widerstand leisten können. Eine ist, wir können technische Mittel gegen Überwachungssysteme entwickeln, das heißt Verschlüsselung, Analyseum und so weiter und so fort. Da wird man ein bisschen später noch ein bisschen in die Toilette drauf eingehen. Und das ist auch ein sehr wesentlicher Teil, weil schlicht und ergreifend politische Mittel helfen nicht kurzfristig. Und der einzige Weg, irgendwie nicht in das Überwachungsraster zu gelangen, sei es von Firmen, sei es vom Staat, ist halt zu wissen, wie die funktionieren und sich technologische Mittel auszudenken, um halt gegen diese Technologie anzustecken. So, das ist eine Sache, die wir tun können und die auch schon passiert, wo viele Leute ihre Zeit und ihr Engagement reinstecken. Und das andere ist, wir müssen diese Kultur umdrehen. Wir müssen diesen Leuten, die da irgendwie ihre perverse Neugier befriedigen, halt einfach mal klarmachen, dass sie halt einfach mal spanner sind.
Wie willst du das machen? Wie machst du vier Millionen Bildzeitungslesern klar, dass sie sich gerade gemein machen mit Schmutz?
Interessante Frage.
Fighting the War, das Thema im Chaosradio 110. Ihr seid natürlich nach wie vor eingeladen anzurufen unter 0331 77 97 110 zu erzählen, wie ihr den Krieg...
Das geht mir kaputt.
Was, du hast was verloren? Der Krieg gegen dein Telefon.
Tümac zu viel Hardtail.
Hast du eigentlich auch das Problem mit diesem Joystick-Steuernupsi an deinem Telefon?
Nee, hatte ich gestern schon alle davon, aber ich hab das nicht.
Freigestellte Singweisengriffer.
Der was?
Das ist aus irgendeiner Bedienungsanleitung, die so aus dem Suaheli übers Hongkong-Chinesische ins Deutsche übersetzt worden ist. Und eigentlich sollte damit bezeichnet werden, die Möglichkeit, verschiedene Klingeltöne umzustellen. Das ist eingedeutscht worden mit freigestellter Singweisengriffer.
Das sagt Peter Glaser. Außerdem im Studio heute Abend der Frank, der Pavel, der Tim und die Knöpfe.
Und der Rob.
Und der Rob, der ist immer noch am Telefon. Bist du eigentlich noch am Telefon, Rob?
Ich bin noch da.
Das ist toll, ne? Endlich mal lange nach Deutschland telefonieren.
Also bisher haben wir sozusagen alles richtig gesagt, ja?
Okay, wir haben zwei Anrufer. Zum einen ist es der Holger. Du hast eine Frage, oder?
Nein, ich wollte eigentlich etwas Stellung nehmen, was gerade eben gesagt wurde, die Kontodatenabfrage.
Ah, die Kontodatenabfrage, ja.
Weil ja da ein ganz falscher Eindruck entsteht. Zum einen glaubt ja die Mehrheit der Leute, die darüber diskutiert, dass tatsächlich da Finanzbeamte direkt auf Kontos schauen können und Kontostände und sowas erfahren können, was nicht der Fall ist. Und auch die Zahlen, die da im Umlauf sind, sind völlig übertrieben eigentlich.
Dann was ist denn wahr?
Die Kontodatenabfrage heißt, dass der Finanzbeamte über die BaFin herausfinden kann, wo jemand ein Konto hat. Also Kontostandarten. Das heißt, er fragt nach einer Person, beispielsweise Holger Klein, und dann kann er darüber herausfinden, wo der überall Kontos und Depots hat. Wir bekommen nur diese Information und nicht die Information, was da drauf ist. Dazu müsste er dann extra zur Bank gehen.
Aber er kann doch den Kontostand abfragen. Das ist doch tatsächlich die Sozialbehörden massenweise mit den Hartz IV.
Nein, das geht nicht. Das geht schon technisch nicht. Die haben einen Zugriff auf eine Datei, wo in der Bank drin steht, wer hat da ein Konto.
Naja, aber was ich positiv weiß, ist, dass die Beamten, wie heißt die Arbeitsamt da heutzutage, dass die tatsächlich in der Lage sind, den Kontostand ihrer Delinquenz zu nehmen.
Aber nicht auf elektronischem Wege. Auch bei den Finanzbeamten ist es ja schon immer so, das ist ja keine Neuerung, dass die zur Nachprüfung, ob jemand richtige Angaben gemacht hat, bei seiner Steuererklärung, bei der Beantragung können, auf das Konto zu gucken.
Also sie haben Zugriff auf die Stammdaten, sie haben nicht Zugriff auf den Kontostand.
Soweit ich das Gesetz kenne und höre aus den Ämtern, ist durchaus, dass die den Zugriff auf den Kontostand problemlos bekommen können.
Das muss man dann noch mal recherchieren. Ich habe hier einen NTV-Beitrag, der von Stammdaten spricht.
Elektronisch geht es nur über die Stammdaten. Alles andere muss dann einzeln bei der Bank beantragt werden. Das erfährt dann aber auch der jeweilige betroffene Bürger. Ich arbeite für einen Bundestagsabgeordneten, der im Finanzausschuss ist. Wir befassen uns mit der Frage sehr intensiv.
Dann hör weiter zu.
Darf ich noch ganz kurz eins sagen, was die Zahlen angeht. Da ist es auch so, dass es im letzten Jahr etwa 80.000, 90.000 abgefahren waren.
Das ist auch schon Wahnsinn, oder?
Ja gut, bei 80 Millionen Deutschen finde ich nicht so wahnsinnig viel.
Und noch mal eine kurze Nachfrage. Aber wenn sozusagen nur irgendein Beamter meine Kontostammdaten erfahren will, bekomme ich keine Benachrichtigung, richtig?
Doch, allerdings erst im Nachhinein. Aus der Steuererklärung steht das drin.
Das heißt also, ich...
Auf dem Steuerbescheid, Entschuldigung.
Okay, und wenn ein Sozialbeamter meinen Kontostand abfragt, bekomme ich das wie gesagt?
Also NTV spricht aber von 14 Millionen Abfragen im letzten Jahr und 20 Millionen erwartet.
Das lässt sich aber leicht erklären.
In Hessen, Rheinland-Pfalz, Saarland, Thüringen, Sachsen.
Das liegt aber daran, dass der Finanzbeamte oder die BaFin eine Anfrage an alle deutschen Banken stellt. Im Bild habt ihr den Namen Holger Klein in eurer Datei. Also multipliziert sich jede Anfrage mit der Anzahl der deutschen Banken.
Das sind ein paar hundert. Da kommen noch nicht so viele 14 Millionen.
Aber er meint, das ist immer dieselbe Frage.
Das kommt nicht nur an einzelne Banken, sondern auch die ganzen Fondanbieter und all sowas ist da drin.
Okay, also alle Institutionen, die bei der Waffen registriert sind. Genau. Das heißt also sozusagen, um noch mal zu präzisieren, damit ich es richtig verstanden habe, irgendein Beamter möchte gerne wissen, wo ich über Konten habe, piept diese Anfrage bei der BaFin rein. Die BaFin leitet diese Anfrage an alle bei ihr registrierten Institutionen ein. Und die müssen dann jeweils antworten. Und dann bekommt der Beamte von der BaFin wiederum eine Liste von allen meinen Konten.
Holger, wenn ich das nicht möchte, in welches Land verlage ich denn meine finanziellen Transaktionen? Wo hole ich mir ein Girokonto? Österreich?
Österreich wäre eine Möglichkeit. Nur ist das im Grunde für die meisten von uns ja völlig uninteressant.
Naja, ich will nicht, dass irgendjemand weiß, wo ich ein Konto habe. Jeden geht das wirklich einen feuchten Kehricht an.
Aber andererseits hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt mehrfach entschieden, dass die Erhebung von Steuern nur dann akzeptabel und verfassungsgemäß ist, wenn sichergestellt werden kann, dass sie auch jeder gleichmäßig zahlen muss. Und diese Mittel und Dinge sind ja im Wesentlichen...
Das ist aber doch jetzt, da wird es dann aber doch lächerlich. Dann sollte doch zuallererst mal die Bundesregierung oder wer auch immer dafür zuständig ist, dafür sorgen, dass Leute, die in Deutschland ihr Geld verdienen, das auch in Deutschland versteuern, zum Beispiel solche Leute wie Franz Beckenbauer. Also, sorry, aber da kann ich dann wirklich nur drüber lachen. Also von wegen...
Du meinst, du als Vorbildgesteuerte Bürger bist du da nicht so ganz...
Nee, absolut nicht. Ich meine, wie soll ich sagen, hey, ich fühle das super?
Es gibt auch Doppelbestellungsabkommen mit anderen Ländern. Da ist es nicht so ganz einfach zu sagen, die sollen einfach auch ihr Steuern zahlen.
Also, vielen Dank für diese Korrektur. Wieder mal ein schönes Beispiel dafür, dass alles, was in den Medien steht, nicht immer die Wahrheit sein muss.
Natürlich nicht. Wir sind die Medien. Was erwartest du?
Weil man sich schon diese Journalisten anguckt.
Glücklicherweise sind keine hier.
Was ich noch mal fragen wollte, war, dieser Prozess, diese Erstellung dieses Gesetzes, du hast da wirklich ein bisschen Einblick, hat es dadurch den Eindruck, dass das tatsächlich eine Sachdiskussion ist, die da geführt wird, oder steht da eher der Eindruck, dass die Leute, die diskutieren, keine Ahnung haben, wovon sie da sprechen?
Auch in dem Fall gab es schon eine Sachdiskussion, weil das im Grunde auch eine Reaktion darauf war, dass es verschiedene Klagen auch im Bundesverfassungsgericht gab, die beispielsweise die Spekulationsbesteuerung für einige zurückliegende Jahre in Frage gestellt haben. Und da ging es dann immer um die Frage, kann denn diese Besteuerung effektiv sichergestellt werden? Und so ist man darauf gekommen, das überhaupt einzuführen.
Wird denn demnächst das Bargeld verboten eigentlich, wenn, ich meine, das wäre dann der nächste konsequente Schritt, weil solche Bar-Transaktionen müssen sich dann auch irgendwie, da habe ich ja auch die Chance, der Steuer zu entgehen.
Ja, natürlich wird man das nie völlig ausschließen. Man ist da der Fantasie der Steuerhinterzieher, ist man immer im Hinterherlaufen. Aber ich finde das in dem Fall nicht richtig, das zu dramatisieren einfach.
Na gut, aber was du sagst, ist sozusagen, dass die Diskussion eigentlich mehr pekonitär getrieben war. Also zu sagen, okay, wir haben dann ein Problem, wir haben zu viele Leute, die ihre Steuern hinterziehen, wir haben dann irgendwie diese ganzen Leute, die irgendwie noch Kohle auf dem Konto haben und irgendwie Hartz IV beantragen. Die brauchen irgendein Mittel, um denen habhaft zu werden. Und dabei ist zumindest aus meiner Sicht irgendwie ein normales Bankengeheimnis, was für mich schon so ein gewisser Grundfest der kapitalistischen Gesellschaft war, einfach mal so pochal hinten runtergefallen. Und das war sozusagen meine Frage, ob dieser Aspekt in der Diskussion überhaupt irgendeine Rolle spielte, oder ob das eigentlich mehr so um die, wie die Firma das technisch durch und wie verkaufen wir das ging.
Natürlich hat das eine Rolle gespielt. Es gab ja auch viele dagegen waren. Also FDP zum Beispiel war ein großer Verteidiger. Wobei dann die Frage ist, wird da eher das Bankgeheimnis verteidigt oder die Steuerhinterzieher, die das auch nutzen.
Na gut, bloß gibt es ja mehrere Gründe, mich nicht zu wollen, dass irgendwie jede publik über Amtinnen auf einem Amt auf mein Konto gucken kann. Das kann halt einfach sein, dass ich das nicht möchte. Ich möchte gerne meine Steuern in diesem Land zahlen, weil ich gute Gründe dafür habe. Aber ich möchte eigentlich, dass ich meinen Staat mir gegenüber fair verhält. Das ist genauso ein Grund, wie, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es dem öffentlichen Rundfunk sagen darf, die GEZ. Die meisten Leute würden schon gerne Rundfunkgebühren zahlen. Bloß haben sie keinen Bock auf diese Leute, die an der Tür klingeln und sagen, sie wären der Fernsehreparateur. Das ist für mich so ein ähnlicher Aspekt. Ich möchte einfach, dass sich mein Staat und wer auch immer von mir geldmäßig mir gegenüber fair verhält. An dem Punkt kommen dann schon gewisse Zweifel, dass das der Fall ist.
Aber es ist aber schon so, dass das auf das Konto gucken schon seit Jahrzehnten möglich ist. Diese Kontodatenabfrage hat jetzt nur noch die Möglichkeit geschaffen, die Konten auch tatsächlich alle zu finden. Früher konnten die Beamten nur auf Konten gucken, von denen sie schon wussten, dass sie existieren. Das ist eigentlich die wesentliche Neuerung.
Ja, danke für deine Anruffolger. So, Tim, du hattest noch was rausgesucht?
Ja, hatte ich.
Warte, ich lass erst mal sagen, wie die Sendung heißt.
Ja, ich hab's ja auch schon wieder vergessen. Wie war das?
Was? Wie die Sendung heißt? Ja. Warte mal, die Sendung heißt... Nein, der Sender heißt... Der Sender heißt...
heißt... Mist! Ich hab drüber gehört.
Chaosradio 1 und 10 ist es, was ihr hört. Fighting the War, das Thema, der Kampf um... Um was eigentlich? Um unsere Freiheit?
Ja, um die Freiheit. So, und jetzt können wir mal kurz den vorhin angekündigten Clip hier einspielen. Und es klappt. Ich hoffe, dass es klappt. Sollte eigentlich klappen. Von John Gilmore, wie er diese Geschichte mit dem Suspected Terrorist erzählt.
Und ich habe diesen Knopfgewehr, der Suspected Terrorist, geworfen.
Und ich würde dich gerne aus dem Knopf ausnehmen. Und ich sagte, nein, das ist ein politisches Statement, etc.
Ja, immer wieder schön. Wie ist er denn dann überhaupt geflogen? Also ich meine, was hat er dann...
Er hat dann später nochmal einen Flug genommen.
Ich weiß jetzt im Einzelnen nicht ganz genau, wie die Diskussion ausgegangen ist, aber er ist dafür bekannt, dass er das dann auch wirklich sehr stringent durchzieht. Mir ist jetzt nicht bekannt, ob er es geschafft hat, auf dem zweiten Flug mit Button zu fliegen. Ich glaube irgendwann hat er sicherlich auch ein Interesse daran gehabt, mal anzukommen, was ja auch wieder immer so ein Problem ist. Das Gelächter und so weiter im Hintergrund, das war halt, weil er das im Rahmen seines Vortrags auf dem Camp 2003 gemacht hat.
Okay, wir haben eine Telefonnummer, die heißt 0331 70 97 110. Ihr seid eingeladen anzurufen, euch am Kampf um die Freiheit zu beteiligen bzw. vielleicht eine andere Frage zu stellen, wie man denn für die Freiheit kämpfen kann oder ob nicht vielleicht sogar alles schon längst verloren ist. Angerufen hat die Frauke. Hallo Frauke.
Ja, also da kann man total was gegen machen. Aber leider wird man auch immer wieder unterbunden, dass man was macht. Ich habe 2000er, wo dieser Anschlag war, habe ich am 13.11. einen Artikel kam in die Zeitung, den ich geschrieben habe. Also hier in Kiel. Und die Überschrift war halt Terroranschlag. Und glaubt ihr denn alles? Und habe halt so geschrieben, dass man noch ein bisschen kritisch sein soll, was in Amerika passiert, dass nicht alles gleich von anderen Leuten kommt, dass das eventuell auch von den eigenen oberen Leuten kommt, wie zum Beispiel in den US-Ländern halt so die eigenen Dinge. Haben sie ja auch explodieren, das sind die Hochhäuser, nur damit sie einen Krieg machen können. Und das war ja das Gleiche, ist ja auch passiert. Es ist genauso gekommen, wie ich in einem Artikel geschrieben habe, dass da ein Krieg passiert und alles nur wegen Öl. Und leider hat jemand aus Berlin da eine Gegenanzeige geschrieben für diesen Lisa-Brief. Also kam prompt gleich nächsten Tag rein, nach dem Motto, wer behauptet denn sowas und das kann ja wohl nicht sein. Und irgendwie kamen auch gewisse Herren, haben versucht, aus dem Ort, wo ich herkomme, alle mit meinen Nachnamen anzurufen.
Gewisse Herren?
Ja, ich denke, es ist der BND gewesen. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, aber solche Leute aus Berlin.
Der Bundesnachrichtendienst soll reagiert haben auf einen Leserbrief, den du an eine lokale Zeitung geschrieben hast, wenn ich das gerade richtig verstanden habe.
Richtig.
Entschuldige, aber das kann ich mir aber bestens nicht vorstellen, dass der Bundesnachrichtendienst bei solchen Sachen aktiv ist.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wer das sein kann. Ich meine, oft beherstellt sich bei allen möglichen Leuten, die mit meinen Nachnamen in meinem Ort wohnten, vor einem komischen Namen und...
Also der BND ist unwahrscheinlich, weil sich der BND um die Auslandsaufklärung kümmert.
Und warum hat er nicht bei dir geklingelt?
Ja, weil ich habe einen anderen Ort angegeben, wo ich wohne. Der Nachname stimmt, das war. Und daraufhin kam ich natürlich auch prompt. Natürlich haben die auch ein paar Verwandte von mir erwischt, ist klar. Bekam ich dann auch böse Anrufe, wie ich dann sowas machen kann und wie ich sowas behaupten könnte. Und das wäre ja unmöglich, wie kann ich sowas behaupten? Und naja, und dann...
Meinungen haben verboten.
Ja, richtig. Ich finde trotzdem, man sollte seine Meinung ruhig sagen. Es entpuppte sich letztendlich schon irgendwie als wahr. Man kann es ja immer noch nicht behaupten. Es ist natürlich klar, dass Hochhäuser immer so runtergesprengt werden. Und es ist auch doof, dass ich das gleich am nächsten Tag geschrieben habe. Und es ist auch doof, dass die Zeitung das abgedruckt hat. Es ist natürlich alles ungünstig. Und auch bei den Wahlen, die letztes Mal abliefen, habe ich auch überall angerufen, weil wir immer Bleistifte benutzen und die man wegradieren kann. Und das finde ich auch nicht richtig.
Entschuldigung, wer benutzt bei welchen Wahlen Bleistifte, die man wegradieren kann?
Zum Beispiel bei den Bundestagswahlen.
Wer benutzt da Bleistifte?
Also vielleicht ist es nur bei uns hier oben in Norden. Aber wir benutzen Bleistifte.
Also die Bundeswahlordnung sagt, dass Dokumenten echte Stifte verwenden werden müssen. Und wenn das nicht der Fall ist, dann kannst du zum Bundeswahlleiter gehen und deinen lokalen Wahlleiter...
Ich habe, also weil die Jahre davor auch schon Bleistifte benutzt worden sind, haben sie mir gesagt, das sind nicht kopierbare Bleistifte. Aufgrund dessen habe ich das nächste Mal bei den nächsten Wahlen, egal welche Wahlen übrigens, habe ich halt meinen Bleistift mitgenommen oder einen anderen oder wie auch immer und einen Radierer und habe versucht, deren wegzumachen. Das ging ganz einfach. Das ist ein HB-Bleistift, ganz normal. Dann bin ich vorne hin zu diesen Lokalleitern und habe gesagt, man kann das wegradieren, darf ich meinen Kugelschrauber benutzen? Dann hat derjenige gesagt, ja, aber das ist ja auch nicht richtig. Dann sehen wir ja, was sie gewählt haben. Was? Ja, und ich dachte, das kann auch nicht möglich sein. Und dann habe ich halt...
Hast du dich mal an den Bundeswahlleiter gewandt deswegen?
Ich habe angerufen, nächstes Mal bei der Wahl, schon vor, weil der Gesacher, der bei der Wahl, der Lokalleiter hat gerade gesagt, man sollte da anrufen, habe ich das auch getan. Und die haben gesagt, nein, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Zufall gewesen. Und das kann ich, das ist wahrscheinlich der Hausmeister, der falsche Sachen ausübt, die dürfen nicht radierbar sein. Ich so, ja, das weiß ich. Ich bin mir dessen bewusst, dass es nicht radiert werden darf. Und die haben trotzdem Bleistiftung laufen, habe ich halt mein Kugelschreiber benutzt. Aber das Problem ist, es ist nicht nur bei mir gesehen. Ich habe natürlich darauf dessen, hatte ich schon vor, alle meine Freunde aus allen möglichen Teilen anrufen gehabt und gefragt, ob das bei denen auch so ist und sollten noch bitte einen Radierer mitbringen, um das nachzuprüfen. Und es war überall. Und dann frage ich mich schon so ein bisschen, darf das sein? Dann raufhin habe ich dann hier von der CDU, ich weiß jetzt nicht, versucht, Leute von der Politik zu erreichen. Ich habe gesagt, nein, nein, nein, das kann nicht sein. Dann habe ich bei verschiedenen Zeitungen angerufen, die haben auch gesagt, das kann ja nicht sein. Das ist ja ganz toll, das ist ein toller Artikel und blablabla. Da kann man ja was ganz Tolles rausmachen. Und habe sogar beim Fernsehen angerufen. Aber es war denen wohl alles zu heil. Die haben zwar alle total toll drauf reagiert. Und von denen, ja, das mussten wir sofort berichten.
Warum hast du es denn nicht selber dokumentiert? Ich meine, also...
Na ja, eine Art Journal im Internet.
Nee, ich habe kein Internet. Das bringt übrigens gar nichts. Man versucht natürlich, dann dagegenzusteuern. Ich habe auch wirklich alles Mögliche versucht, dass man so mal drauf aufmerksam macht. So, hallo Leute, reagiert doch mal jemand drauf.
Vor allen Dingen solltest du es, Frauke, das ist ganz prima, dass du dich eschaufierst darüber, aber du solltest es vor allen Dingen dokumentieren. Weil niemand wird dir glauben, wenn du erzählst, dass da mit einem Bleistift die Kreuze gemacht werden, solange du das nicht belegen kannst.
Ich habe mir einen Zettel mitgenommen gehabt und habe ihn da auf den Kreuz gemacht. Also sehr gradiert und das hängt jetzt bei mir hier auf dem Flur im Bilderrahmen, die Bundestagswahl, blablabla. Also das ist meine Reaktion da drauf, weil es hat überhaupt nichts gebracht.
Nimm das nächste Mal einen Fotoapparat, mit Fotografiers und Dokumentiers, und zwar so wasserdicht, dass du es selber veröffentlichen kannst.
Darf man denn in dem Raum fotografieren? Hoho, halt.
Nein, darf man eigentlich nicht.
Darf man nicht?
Ich durfte nur ausnahmsweise meinen Stift benutzen. Sollte man eigentlich auch nicht.
Naja, also Fotoapparate sind heute so klein, dass du ihnen noch von nichts erzählen musst.
Wenn das wirklich stimmt, dann wäre das ein Scoop, den sich keine Wochenzeitschrift für die Titelseite entgehen lassen würde.
Ja, aber das Komische ist, es hat wirklich keiner reagiert. Ich habe bestimmt acht Leute, also acht angesagte Leute angerufen, die waren alle mutiert und blablabla und alles, aber die haben nichts gemacht.
Ja, weil du es nicht dokumentieren konntest.
Ja, ich habe das ja auch noch während der Wahl gemacht. Ich habe gesagt, ihr könnt schnell hingehen. Ein paar sind ja auch zur Wahl noch hingegangen.
Was glaubst du, mal ernsthaft, was glaubst du eigentlich, wie viele Bekloppte täglich bei so einem Medium anrufen und irgendwas erzählen? Das ist das Problem. Entweder du kannst es dokumentieren, und zwar aus dem Stand, oder dir wird niemand zuhören. Das ist immer so. Nur weil irgendjemand anruft und sagt, da hinten stinkt's, wird kein Ü-Wagen losfahren und kein Reporter sich in Bewegung setzen.
Zum Beispiel hab ich auch bei uns ein Radio angerufen hier in Ländern. Und die haben gesagt, oh ja, sie sind heute die fünfte Person, die es angerufen hat. Aufgrund dessen. Weil schon viele das auch von anderen Kreisen entdeckt haben, dass es ein Bleistift ist.
Aber hat sie trotzdem nicht interessiert.
Also Frank hat sich das jetzt mal notiert und wird sicherlich mal beim Bundeswahlleiter jetzt nachfragen, was das denn damit auf sich hat.
Soweit bin ich ja auch schon gewesen. Und die haben gesagt, selbst wenn es so wäre, könnte man es ja immer noch überprüfen, ob das geht. Und zwar könnte man ja bei der Auszahl, also wenn die abzählen, wird ja öffentlich ausgezählt. Also angeblich kann man da öffentlich hingehen und sich da hinsetzen, um zuzugucken, was sie auszählen. Das Problem ist doch nicht da. Ja gut, dann haben sie es gezählt.
Aber es kommt nachher alles in einen Topf. Wir schauen uns das mal an. Und du guckst beim nächsten Mal bei der öffentlichen Auszählung einfach mal zu, was da so ausgezählt wird. Und dann kannst du immer noch Stopp rufen.
Ich glaube, da wird das Problem sein. Also es wird halt nicht ausgezählt. Das ist ja auch kein Problem. Aber nachher werden ja die ganzen Stimmen in einen Topf geschmissen.
Ist das hier was ich meine? Ja, wir verstehen dein Anliegen. Können aber jetzt natürlich auch nichts weiter machen. Aber wir werden mal ein bisschen nachforschen.
Danke.
Bitte?
Achso.
Danke für deinen Anruf. Ja, so hatte ich das verstanden, das Danke. Wer ist denn das da hinter dir?
Wahlen. Ich meine, das ist fast, ich weiß nicht, wollen wir das fast jetzt auch noch aufmachen mit den Wahlen? Das wird jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen zu weit.
Die Lehre ist aber, wenn man irgendwelche Dinge feststellt, man muss sie einfach wirklich dokumentieren.
Ja, sonst hast du überhaupt keine Chance.
Ja gut, hat sie ja durchaus in dem Fall gemacht. Das klang schon nicht ganz verkehrt. Allerdings meine Meinung dazu ist noch im Vergleich zu digitalen Wahlmaschinen ohne Paper Trail ist selbst einen Strich auf einem, also einen Bleistiftstrich auf einem Papier noch eigentlich vorzuziehen. Aber ja, Frank hört einfach mal nach, was da drin ist.
Interessant fand ich den Anderen noch einmal mit der Stammdatenabfrage, weil es einen gewissen Einblick in diese Politikerdenke gab. Den fand ich insofern interessant, als man sich gedanken macht darüber, wie entstehen solche Gesetze. Jetzt haben wir gerade noch als wesentlich schlimmeres Problem die sogenannte Vorratsdatenspeicherung, die nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern auch europaweit eingeführt wird, wo je nach landestypischer Auslegung für mindestens 6 Monate die Begleitdaten von allen Kommunikationsvorgängen gespeichert werden. Also wer ruft wem von wo an, zu welcher Zeit, wer schickt wem eine E-Mail, wer klickt auf welche Webseite, wer chattet wo und wie, all diese ganzen Dinge sollen gespeichert werden. Und die Art und Weise, wie diese Speicherung durchgeprügelt wurde, spottet halt wirklich jeder Beschreibung, hat mit Demokratie genau gar nichts mehr zu tun. Also da kann mir auch der überzeugteste Demokrat noch irgendwelche Argumente bringen, es war schlicht einfach mal nicht mehr demokratisch.
Das war doch der gute alte Europatrick. Eigentlich sind wir ja dagegen, aber die EU will das so und wir können uns nicht wehren, obwohl wir vorher der EU gesagt haben, dass sie das so wollen soll.
Und das zeigt eigentlich sozusagen wohin die Reise da geht. Das heißt, dass sozusagen diese ganzen Begleitfolgen für die Gesellschaft nur am Rande vorkommen. Das heißt also, dass erst mal das unmittelbare Problem gelöst werden soll, nämlich da hinter zehn Leuten steuern oder da beantragen Leute Art 4, ohne irgendwie dafür berechtigt zu sein oder was auch immer. Aber sozusagen der Blick aufs Ganze unterbleibt. Es wird halt nicht geguckt, welche Folgen hat denn diese Datensammerlei auf den Rest der Gesellschaft.
Das ist ja auch wieder ein grundlegendes Problem der parlamentarischen Demokratie, weil natürlich der Parlamentarier in erster Linie seine Wiederwahl im Auge hat und darum nicht weiter als vier Jahre denken muss, was er wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal kann. Weil alles, was nach der nächsten Wahl liegt, ist erst mal irgendwas, was ihn nicht interessiert, weil das Wichtigste für ihn die nächste Wahl ist. Das ist ja ein grundlegendes Problem.
Vielleicht sollten wir mit Vorratsdatensprechungen über Parlamentarier anfangen.
Ja, habe ich ja sowieso schon mal gesagt, man sollte einfach mal hingehen und den Innenminister fotografieren, wann immer man ihn sieht und diese Bilder ins Netz packen, in das Innenminister-Blog oder so. Einfach damit er einen Eindruck davon kriegt, wie es ist, ständig beobachtet zu werden. Und zwar nicht von normalen Fernsehteams.
Es gibt doch diese VIP-Jäger, die es ohnehin schon mit irgendwelchen Schauspielern machen. Pöfliche Paparazzi. Vielleicht sollten die sie einfach mal Politiker auf ihre Liste stellen.
Ja, dann weiß man auch mal wenigstens, wie die aussehen. Sonst geht man ja auch nicht mit.
In Amerika gibt es ja diese Aktion schon, wo jemand ein Kopfgeld auf einen Sheriff in Höhe von 1500 Dollar ausgesetzt hat, für denjenigen, dem es gelingt, ihn mit einer Kamera bei einer Straftat zu überführen. Das ist derjenige, der gesagt hat, wer nichts zu verheimlichen hat, der hat auch nichts zu befürchten, dieses Argument.
Der Klassiker.
Ja, aber nochmal zur Vorrats.
Dieser Klassiker, darf ich mal kurz? Dieser Klassiker wird aber immer mehr wahr. Entschuldigung, meine Stimme ist noch mehr weg als normal, ich bin eigentlich krank. Dieser Klassiker wird aber immer mehr wahr. Wer nichts zu verheimlichen hat, hat nichts zu befürchten. Früher war es so, dass Diktatur verdammt unkomfortabel war. Auch wenn man nichts zu verheimlichen hatte, war das eine verdammt unkomfortable Staatsform. Und wo wir jetzt hingehen, das wird so verdammt komfortabel sein. Das wird die meist vernünftige Diktatur, die es jemals gegeben hat. Es gibt nicht mehr dieses Wissen, wo wir alle waren und was wir alle getan haben, so präzise und so leicht automatisch zu verwerten, dass wir da auch wirklich nur die Leute was antun können, die auch wirklich gefährlich im Augen von Staat sind.
Ja, zum Beispiel die Leute, die sich krankschreiben lassen, aber in Wirklichkeit gar nicht krank sind, sondern dann mit ihrem Handy munter durch die Stadt spazieren, obwohl sie ja eigentlich krank sein müssten.
Das ist der gleiche Argument wie vor eben. Das Ganze mit dem Krankengeld zahlen geht nur, wenn wir alle gleich Krankengeld zahlen müssen, wenn wir krank sind.
Kannst du nochmal dieses Gegenwirken bei euch, dieses Projekt?
Ja, das ist auch wichtig. Bei uns in Holland gibt es jetzt, die Polizei macht hier eine neue Strategie. Die lösen keine Straftaten mehr, weil das können die eh nicht. Da sind die europaweit, glaube ich, ziemlich unten. Was sie hier machen, ist so die bekannte kriminellen Gegenwirken. Was das heißt, ist den ganzen Tag hinterher laufen, jedes Mal stoppen, wenn das Auto vorbeikommt, weil wir haben eh alle so einen Computer im Auto und wir machen auch schon License plate recognition vom Polizeiauto aus automatisiert. Das einfach blipp macht, wenn das Auto vorne nicht in Ordnung ist. Also jedes Mal stoppen, jedes Mal alles kontrollieren, alle Papiere, bis die Leute dann auswandern oder verrückt werden oder wie auch immer. Und das heißt dann Gegenwirken. Einfach es die Kriminellen, die so ebekannt sind, so schwierig machen. Also nicht mit Richter, sondern Strafe einfach, weil wir sie nicht mögen.
Das macht die Brandenburg, in Brandenburg passiert das auch gerne mit Rechtsradikalen. Ja, irgendwelche Polizisten, denen die ganze Zeit auf den Keks gehen.
Hier ist es aber sehr, sehr, sehr definierte Policy. Es ist beschrieben, es ist definiert. Die sagen noch, wir machen das so. Die Politik will das auch so haben. Das ist einfach nichts Heimliches, was sie hier machen.
In Berlin lief das eher so am Rande gegen Linksextremisten früher, dass dort halt dann einfach permanent die Polizei in Wannstärke vor dem Haus parkte.
Bis jetzt geht es anders, weil jetzt sind die Daten manchmal im Spiel.
Darf ich nur mal kurz weiter? Was wichtig ist an diesem Gegenwirken, ist, dass es Strafe ist, ohne dass man Richter dafür belästigen muss. Und was daran wichtig ist, ist, wir haben in der Zukunft mit all dieser Data Mining einen ganzen Haufen Daten, wovon wir mit so 90% Sicherheit sagen können, die gefallen uns oder die gefallen uns nicht. Wir wissen aber nicht, warum nicht. Wir haben keine Ahnung. Das Data Mining Algorithmus liefert das nicht dazu. Nur wir wissen mit 95% Sicherheit, der ist nicht in Ordnung. So ein Mechanismus ist dann verdammt bequem. Und wenn dann auch noch die Leute, die es ausführen, nicht mal wissen, aus welchem Grund die da diese Inspektion durchführen. Zum Beispiel Steuerinspektion. Wer inspektiert wird, wer alles vorzeigen muss, das kommt jetzt schon aus ziemlich viele Random-Zahlen. Wenn dein Einkommen mehr als 1, 3 Mal das, was normal ist, in deine Klasse, dann wird die Chance, dass man inspektiert wird, in einem gewissen Jahr mit 0, irgendwas steigen. Wenn man nur diese Zahlen hoch und runter drehen kann, bei der ganzen Bevölkerung oder bei Teilen davon, dann kann man ziemlich genau kontrollieren, ohne dass man irgendwas, nur ein Beispiel, aber dann kann man ziemlich genauer Kontrolle machen, ohne dass irgendjemand nur nachweisen kann, dass er benachteilt ist.
Also was dann passiert ist? Automatisierte, willkürliche Verfolgung?
Gingelungen. Na nicht willkürlich, nach Data-Mining. Also ganz gezielt bestimmte Gruppen gegenwirken oder bestimmte Gruppen bevorteilen, geht ja auch.
Womit wir dann schon in die Nähe von Minority Report wären, wo man halt die Leute, die statistisch mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit vielleicht wieder straftätig werden, dass man die halt von vornherein bestraft, belästigt, ihnen das Leben schwer macht.
Man muss aber nicht in die Zukunft, wir können sagen, was in der Zukunft passiert, sondern einfach die Leute, wovon wir wissen, wenn wir die gegenwirken, dann geht der Gesellschaft in Richtung A. Und wenn wir eine andere Gruppe gegenwirken, dann geht die Gesellschaft in Richtung B und wir bevorzugen A.
Und du bist ja dann auch ganz schnell da, wo dann irgendwelche Soziologen vielleicht mal mehr oder minder gerichtsfest belegen können, dass der Apfel nicht weit vom Stamm fällt. Und darum bist du dann als Kind eines Vorbestraften ja ohnehin schon mal gefährdet, vielleicht selber irgendwann mal ein Verbrechen zu begehen. Also da wird das Netz auch immer feinmaschiger irgendwann.
Tja, was tun dagegen?
Was tun dagegen, ist doch noch die Frage. Bevor wir das erörtern, weil wir müssen ja eh gleich wieder Nachrichten machen, ich habe noch einen Anrufer aus Kiel, wo Frauke auch herkam. Jetzt wird es interessant. Hallo Sven.
Hallo.
Hast du auch Bleistifte in den Wahlkabinen gesehen?
Ich habe auch Bleistifte gesehen und auch benutzt. Also ich habe auch gehört, das gibt so Dokumentechte. Aber kann ich nicht sagen, ob das wirklich waren. Ich hatte kein Radioboomi dabei.
Schade, das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen. Das habe ich jetzt gar nicht gewusst. Vielleicht waren ja noch mehr Leute aus Kiel zu, die gewählt haben.
Ja, vielleicht.
Nee, aber das waren auf jeden Fall definitiv Bleistifte.
Alles klar Sven, vielen Dank. Ja, ich grüße alle. Tschüss. Ich weigere mich, das zu glauben. Die können doch nicht so doof sein, da Bleistifte hinzulegen.
Aber wie sollen sie denn sonst die Kreuze nachher anders machen?
Früher gab es doch Tintenkiller.
Fritz präsentiert A-Pop-Tic-Ma-Berserk.
A-Pop-Tic-Ma-Berserk Live. Mehr Infos fritz.de Und im Radio fritz.
Vom RBB eine nach halb zwölf. Mit Matthias Kerkhoff.
Dem Irak droht nach Ansicht seines Präsidenten Talibani ein Bürgerkrieg. In einer Fernsehansprache appellierte er an seine Landsleute, friedlich zu bleiben. Im ganzen Land war es heute zu blutigen Auseinandersetzungen zwischen Schiiten und Soniten gekommen. Der Bundesnachrichtendienst sollte im Irak doch Angaben über militärische Ziele an US-Stellen weitergegeben haben. Wie Grünen Vizefraktionschef Ströbele im RBB Hörfunk erklärte, hat die Arbeit des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums entsprechende Hinweise erbracht. Die Bundesregierung hat die größte Steuererhöhung in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik beschlossen. Kernpunkt ist die Anhebung der Mehrwertsteuer zu beginn nächsten Jahres auf 19%. Die Gewerkschaft Verdi will die Streiks im öffentlichen Dienst in den kommenden Tagen noch ausweiten. Das kündigte der Fraktbundesvorsitzende Sierske an. Die Beschäftigten wehren sich gegen die geplante Verlängerung der Wochenarbeitszeit auf 40 Stunden. Zum Sport. Werder Bremen hat in der Fußball Champions League sein Achtelfinal-Hinspiel in letzter Minute gewonnen. Die Bremer schlugen sich am Abend auf eigenem Platz mit Juventus Turin 3 zu 2. In dieser Nacht stark bewölkt, überwiegend trocken, zum Morgen im Norden etwas Schnee. Die Temperaturen minus 5 bis minus 2 Grad. Morgen in der Uckermark und Prignitz leichter Schneefall. Ansonsten wolkig und weitgehend trocken bei Höchstwerten zwischen 0 und 2 Grad plus. A24 Schwerin Richtung Berliner Ring. Zwischen Pritzweig und Wittstock-Dosse Gefahr durch Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Und alle anderen Autobahnhindernisse sind inzwischen beseitigt. Wir wünschen gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Matthias Karghoff. 3 Minuten nach halb 12.
Und wenn im Radio 103, 2? Dann Fritz in Spremberg.
Genau.
Das war Pumpernickel.
Pumpernickel.
P-U-M-P-A-N-I-C-E-K-L-E.de Ach, Nicle.
Pumpernickel.de Das klingt ja fast wie so eine Dance-Roll-Truppe.
Eine was für eine Truppe?
Die Pumpernickel Soundsystem.
Pumpernickel.
Pumpernickel. Sie haben einen sehr eindrucksamen Slogan. Hüpfen Sie Ausch.
Das gefällt ihr, ne?
Woher wusstet ihr das?
Das nächste Mal wieder zu hören.
Nach 110 Sendungen.
Also, ich warte noch gar nicht.
Was stand auf dem Schild?
Nur noch mal um die Warblog zu Ende zu machen. Pumpernickel.de Das nächste Mal zu hören auf der Ammer Gänzer, 8. Mai, SU 36.
Da gibt es was zu gewinnen, ne?
Falls jemand hin möchte und ein bisschen hüpfen möchte. Man kann da sehr schön hüpfen zu der Musik. Sie Arsch.
JKS. Radio 110 in Blumuna, Fritz. Fighting the War, den Krieg um die Freiheit kämpfen. Du hast eben, Frank, die These aufgestellt, dass im Grunde der Kampf der letzten 20 Jahre mehr oder minder vergebens war, weil es nicht gelungen ist, zu verhindern, dass die Technologie, die gegen die Freiheit eingesetzt wird, tatsächlich auch eingesetzt wird.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, dass es vergebens war. Ich habe nur gesagt, dass wir verloren haben.
Also ich bin ja da ganz anderer Meinung.
So, ich gehe dann.
Ich denke, natürlich sieht es nicht gut aus für uns auf dem Feld, aber ich bin trotzdem absolut davon überzeugt, dass am Ende die Freiheit einfach den Sieg davontragen wird. Allein schon aus ökonomischen Gründen wird man über kurz oder lang wieder dazu übergehen, so etwas wie das Recht auf Anonymität zum Beispiel zu gewährleisten, weil einfach eine offene, freiheitliche Gesellschaft einfach die produktivere Gesellschaft ist, die einfach, meine These ist auch, dass der kommunistische Block nicht deswegen zusammengebrochen ist, weil den Leuten nicht ermöglicht wurde, ihre Gier auszuleben, sondern weil einfach das System es nicht ermöglicht hat, den Leuten ihr Potenzial voll auszuschöpfen. Und in dem Moment, wo man Menschen verängstigt, verunsichert, führt das dazu, dass der Einzelne sein kreatives Potenzial einfach nicht auslebt. Und in der Summe unterm Strich führt es dann einfach zu einem gesellschaftlichen Niedergang. Das heißt, wenn es uns nicht gelingen wird, das in den Griff zu kriegen, dann wird es vielleicht andere Gesellschaften geben, andere Länder in Asien vielleicht. China wird vielleicht irgendwann zum Hort der Demokratie, weil sie dort feststellen, dass sie für ihre immer komplizierter werdende Gesellschaft dann auch Freiheit, Pluralität brauchen, dass sie halt eine stärkere Kontrolle der Regierenden brauchen. Und hier bei uns entwickelt sich dann alles so zum Überwachungsstaat.
Aber ist denn nicht die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch, dass wir sozusagen eher auf so einen gemeinsam glänzenden gemeinsamen Nenner zwischen China und Europa landen?
Nein, der nächste. Ich fand es jetzt ganz nett, zwei Thesen zu hören. Also ich hab noch einen Anrufer, der auch eine These hat. Wollen wir die mal hören? Oh ja. Das ist nämlich der Richie. Hallo Richie. Wie ist deine These?
Erstmal vielen Dank für das, was ihr macht. Finde ich sehr wertvoll.
Gerne.
Meine These, ich weiß nicht, wer das jetzt gerade aufgestellt hat, kann ich ein Stück weit nachvollziehen. Meine These ist aber einfach aus der eigenen Erfahrung heraus, dass es wirklich so ist, dass es einfach zu viele, ich hab nichts zu verbergen, Sager gibt. Und dass wenn wir als Revolutionäre an unserer Ansgehensweise nichts ändern, dann wird es auf einen extremen hinauslaufen. Dann haben wir das wirklich vorerst mal verloren.
Und was sollten wir ändern, deiner Meinung nach?
Das ist die Frage. Ich glaube, man kann die Leute nicht über das Bewusstsein bewegen, denn nicht jeder hat dieses Bewusstsein und kriegen es auch nicht irgendwie. Das ist schwierig. Aber es gibt, die Bevölkerung bewegt sich in gewisser Weise. Die Leute finden gewisse Sachen gut. Was fällt mir als ein Podcasting kommt zum Beispiel ein Stück weit. Leute eben, was sich Sachen gut fühlen, was vielleicht Mode ist, was man bewerben kann, wenn man über diese Schiene. Das ist aber die Frage, wie bringt man die Informationsfreiheit? Wie macht man die Informationsfreiheit hip?
Also ich glaube ja, dass es sowieso eher die Falschen treffen wird, auch die ganzen Maßnahmen. Ich bin nämlich auch deswegen optimistisch, weil die menschliche Fantasie so dann Überwachungsmaßnahmen auch auszuweichen oder doch Dinge reinzuschmieren. Man muss sich nur angucken, wie halt Sachen in Gefängnisse ein- und ausgeschleust werden. Selbst da gelingt es immer, den Leuten mit viel Fantasie einfach jede, also auch dieses System dort zu überwachen.
Auch das ist aber hoch organisiert, hoch strukturiert und hoch kontrolliert und zwar von ganz wenigen Menschen innerhalb des Gefängnisses. Es ist ja nicht so, dass das ein anarchisches oder quasi anarchistisches Prinzip wäre, was dafür sorgt, dass Drogen in den Knast geschmuggelt werden, weit davon entfernt.
Nee, da stecken natürlich ökonomische Prinzipien.
Aber es ist eben auch kontrolliert, also die Verteilung wird auch kontrolliert. Und wenn der Hauptschmuggler nicht will, dass du deinen Dope kriegst, wenn du da sitzt, dann kriegst du das Dope auch nicht. Also von daher ist dagegen auch nicht zu kämpfen. Zumindest nicht von innerhalb des Systems.
Weil diese Systeme, die gibt es ja nur, die müssen ja nur die Wachsensachen sagen, schmuggeln, schmuggeln, weiß es anders nicht dürfen. Wir können ja quasi auch erst Wege drum herumfinden, wenn es uns schon verboten ist.
Also ich glaube, so ein Kernpunkt ist halt, dass, wie Rob halt schon sagte, die Überwachungsgesellschaft wird höchst komfortabel sein, wenn du tatsächlich nichts tust, was gegen die Regeln verstößt, wenn du halt irgendwie wirklich sklavisch nach den Regeln lebst.
Nee, das hilft dir ja nicht alleine. Du musst auch noch Glück haben, weil wenn du Pech hast, hast du eine Namensgleichheit zu irgendjemanden oder du fällst einfach unglücklicherweise, gehörst du zu den fünf oder zehn Prozent Kollateralschäden, den Unschuldigen, die aber irgendwie wegen der unzureichenden Abgrenzung davon betroffen bist. Aber mag sein, du hast das Recht, dass die 90 Prozent, also dass es aus politischer Sicht immer noch als Erfolg gelten könnte, so 90 Prozent Richtige zu erwischen und zehn Prozent Unschuldige einzusperren. Allerdings haben wir da schon ein kleines Menschenrechtsproblem an der Stelle.
Also ich glaube, das mit den Menschenrechten ist auf dem Rückweg gerade. Wir befinden uns ja gerade durchaus in einer Phase der Gegenaufklärung an dieser Stelle.
Ja, aber da bin ich auch optimistisch. Ich meine, die sind ja auch irgendwann erfunden worden. Die sind ja auch aus dem Nichts erstritten worden irgendwann. Und jetzt weiß man, dass es sowas gibt und dass das grundsätzlich eine gute Idee ist. Insofern denke ich selbst, also das ist vielleicht jetzt ein temporärer Gegentrend, aber in 10, 15 Jahren wird man plötzlich auf ganz neue revolutionäre Ideen kommen. Vielleicht kriegen die Amerikaner ja ein Datenschutzgesetz irgendwann, weil das Chaos so groß wird, dass das wäre durchaus auch ein mögliches Szenario, dass die Scheiße irgendwann so sehr anfängt zu stinken, dass man sich dann doch wieder besinnt. Aber ich bin auch der Meinung, dass es erst mal noch eine Strecke geben wird, wo alles schlimmer werden wird.
Das sagst du, das wird erst mal alles schlimmer und dann wird es den Leuten halt irgendwann zu extrem.
Naja, das heißt also, wenn wir sozusagen darin übereinstimmen, dass es erst mal alles schlimmer wird, stellt sich ja die Frage, wer hier irgendwie knistert mit seinen...
Ja, das ist Pavel.
Pavel knistert.
Mich würde ja nochmal Peters Sicht der Dinge interessieren.
Also wenn gerade von Menschenrechten die Rede war, es gibt ja ein bemerkenswertes Problem, wenn diese Versuche unternommen werden. Das, was Rob vorhin in Holland beschrieben hat, also quasi eine Automatisierung der Problemlösung, eine Automatisierung bei der Erfassung von Kriminalität, von Dingen, die jetzt die Gesellschaft irgendwie als bedrohlich empfinden soll. Mich erinnert das alles an, und es ist so eine etwas bizarre Form von Hoffnung, es gibt eine Tradition solcher Versuche, die bisher alle nicht zum Erfolg geführt haben. Ganz drastisch beschrieben und sehr früh beschrieben hat es Joseph Weizenbaum in seinem berühmten Buch Die Macht der Computer und die Ohnmacht der Vernunft. Der hat eine Geschichte erzählt, wie ein Teil des Vietnamkriegs funktioniert hat, nämlich so, dass Aufklärungsflugzeuge über Vietnam Luftaufnahmen gemacht haben. Diese Luftaufnahmen sind übrigens nach Deutschland im Rechenzentrum dann gebracht worden und dort ausgewertet worden, nach bestimmten Kriterien. Und es ist jetzt schon eine interessante Frage, wie diese Kriterien ausgesehen haben können. Und diese Computer, in denen diese Fotos ausgewertet worden sind, die haben dann auf diesen Fotos umrandete Kästchen ausgespuckt, sogenannte Killboxes, die dann wieder zurück auf die Flughäfen gegangen sind, die dann die Kampfjägerpiloten bekommen haben. Und für die Kampfjägerpiloten bedeutete jedes Kästchen auf so einer Karte, da darf auf alles geschossen werden, was sich bewegt. Also das war, das war egal, ob das jetzt Zivilisten oder Soldaten sind, in diesen Kästchen durfte auf alles geschossen werden. Die interessante Frage bzw. das Problem ist, liegt darin, dass Verantwortung in Maschinen delegiert wird. Weil wenn jetzt Zivilisten getötet werden in einem Krieg, stellt sich die Frage, wer ist dafür verantwortlich? Und wenn man jetzt hingeht und sagt, okay, da kam hier der Pilot, sagt nix, ich habe hier eine Karte gekriegt, I only followed orders. Derjenige, der die Fotos in den Computer reingeschoben hat, sagt, ich bin noch nicht zuständig, die Maschine hat irgendwie darüber bestimmt. Also geht man zu den Programmierern, die die Maschine programmiert haben, die sagen, ich habe hier nichts eingestellt, ich habe einen allgemeinen Algorithmus, keine Ahnung, wer da irgendwie was, das diffundiert. Das heißt, das Problem fängt damit an, dass man was, was eigentlich nur Menschen können, nämlich Verantwortung übernehmen, versucht, auf eine Maschine zu delegieren. Funktioniert hat das Ganze nicht. Die Amerikaner haben den Vietnamkrieg mit dieser Methode auch nicht gewonnen. Das ist sozusagen ein drastisches Beispiel.
Sie werden mit den Mitteln den Krieg gegen den Terror auch nicht gewinnen, mit Sicherheit nicht. Vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht das Ziel, irgendwie den zu gewinnen, sondern ihn einfach nur am Lauschen zu halten.
Frank hat das mal sehr schön in seinem Weblog bezeichnet, als das momentan anvisierte Feindbild. Und das ist im Moment eben der Terrorist. Also das kann in 30 Jahren ist das dann vielleicht wieder der Kinderschenk, oder der Rechtsradikale, oder, oder, oder. Der Rechtsradikale Kinderschön-Terrorist, genau.
Ist das Fazit quasi jetzt, wir müssen, zwar ohne jetzt aufzuhören, aber sehenden Sauges in eine Verschlimmerung hineinlaufen?
Also wir scheinen uns zumindest mal kurzfristig darauf anrichten zu müssen. Aber ich fand, was Peter gerade gesagt hat, das fand ich sehr erhellend, weil letztendlich ist es ja die Frage, wie definiert eine Gesellschaft ihre Regeln? Also wir leben ja in einem Rechtsstaat, was ja eine gewisse Garantie ist, dass sozusagen dein Handeln nach Regeln bewertet wird, die dir vorher bekannt sind.
Und das vor allen Dingen für alle gleich sind.
Die für alle gleich sind. Das ist sozusagen eine Grundlage eines Rechtsstaats.
Das ist Menschenrecht auch, außerdem.
Genau.
Und dass du es aber immer mit Menschen zu tun hast, die sozusagen über diese Regeln befinden, oder sich darüber verständigen.
Und was wir jetzt ja gerade sehen, offensichtlich ist, dass diese Regeln in starren Maschinencode gegossen werden können. Also wir sind an der Schwelle dessen, dass die Technologie soweit ist, dass wir diese Regeln in starren Maschinencode gießen können. Das fängt an mit, du fährst irgendwie bei Rot über die Ampel und kriegst, ohne dass da auch nur einer draufguckt, dein Ticket ausgedruckt. Das geht weiter mit irgendwie, in Holland wird das mit, soweit ich weiß, mit Geschwindigkeitsübertretungen gemacht und wird halt immer weiter alles, was erfassbar ist und automatisiert auswertbar ist, wird halt automatisiert ausgewertet.
Der Maschine ist egal, ob du gerade eine Schwange in deinem Wagen hattest.
An dieser Geschichte aus dem Vietnamkrieg wird auch ganz deutlich, woher das alles kommt. Das kommt vom Militär. Beim Militär gibt es natürlich ein Interesse, bestimmte menschliche Eigenschaften auszuschalten, weil das, was Militärs wollen, stören, zum Beispiel Skrupel, zum Beispiel jemanden, der sich überlegt, ich weiß nicht, Zweifel, also soll ich jetzt auf Zivilisten schießen oder nicht? Das stört. Das stört einfach den Ablauf von einer Befehlskette. Und wenn man das an eine Maschine delegieren kann, kann man diese Befehlskette, sozusagen diese Feuerleitung, wie das beim Militär heißt, optimieren. Damit kann man lästiges Skrupel ausschalten und so weiter und so fort. Und diese Tradition ist in dieser ganzen Überwachungstechnik drin. Das ist die Wurzel sozusagen. Und wenn man das sieht, dann wird auch so der Kern des Problems deutlich. Also dass Menschen versuchen, Probleme, die eigentlich nur Menschen lösen können, mit Hilfe von Maschinen zu lösen. Das kann nicht funktionieren, oder das kann nur auf eine ganz bizarre Art schiefgehen.
Das heißt aber, dass wir sozusagen, eigentlich ist auf der politischen Ebene eine Aufgabe, die Diskussion anzustoßen, in welchen Bereichen kann man solche Dinge tolerieren. Sollen wir bei Rot über die Ampel fahren. Da wurde ich jetzt gerade noch so einzeln. Da kann man hinterher immer noch diskutieren. Ich hatte gerade eine Schwange vor am Auto. Und in welchen Bereichen, also wo sind die Grenzen? Also wo ist es mein Bürgerrecht, dass sich Entscheidungen über mich nicht von Maschinen gefällt werden? Wo ist es mein Bürgerrecht, nicht wie ein Ding behandelt zu werden, um einmal mit John Brunner zu sprechen, der sehr schön sagte, das Schlimmste, was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist, wenn man Menschen wie Dinge behandelt.
Artikel 1.
Das ist tatsächlich ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, der mir jetzt gerade auch erstmal so klar wird in der Formulierung.
Also bei dem... Ich noch mal zu dem Ding, was kann man tun, was soll man tun. Ich meine, es gibt eine politische Dimension und eine technische Dimension. Politisch, denke ich, ist es ganz wichtig, einfach jetzt ganz klar Gegenposition, Gegenforderungen aufzustellen und dafür zu werben und Politiker und Freunde davon zu überzeugen, wie zum Beispiel das Recht auf anonymes Telefonieren zu erkämpfen. Da gibt es durchaus auch Initiativen, die laufen, die das zum Ziel haben, weil einfach die Bewegungsdaten sind da von den Telefonen, die werden erfasst. Das lässt sich technisch einfach nun mal nicht verhindern. Und früher oder später wird auch da eine massive Auswertung kommen. Das heißt, dort ist als Gegenmaßnahme einfach das Endgerät, das Telefon einfach anonym, dass ich meinen Namen nicht angeben muss, wenn ich mir einen Handyvertrag hole, einen Prepaid-Vertrag beispielsweise.
Das braucht du doch gar nicht. Du bist ganz leicht aus diesen Datenbanken wieder rauszuholen, wer du bist.
Auf welche Weise?
Du brauchst da gar nicht zu identifizieren. Deinen Callpattern kannst du mit jedem alten Telefon, den du mal hattest, oder aus jeder anderen Graph, die wir aus der ganzen Bevölkerung haben, fällt deine Identität als erstes raus.
Ja, dann.
Auf welche Weise?
Auf welche Weise? Du bist immer mit den gleichen Leuten unterwegs. Du rufst die gleiche Telefonnummern an. Du rufst zum Beispiel nach zu Hause an. Du rufst Leute an, die nicht auf dem gleichen Zeitpunkt von Telefon umgeschaltet sind. Die nicht zum gleichen Zeitpunkt zu diesem anonymen Handy hingegangen sind. Das ist die erste Schlag, die man macht, wenn man zum Beispiel heute, das ist keine Zukunftsmusik, wenn man heute die ganze Callbestände von einer kriminellen Vereinigung auswertet. Das erste, was man macht, ist erstmal deanimisieren. Alle, die mal ein Telefon gewechselt haben, das fällt in der ersten Runde raus.
Ja, ich finde, es ist trotzdem eine wertvolle Gegenposition. Einmal der Workload-Faktor ist, ich sag mal, es mag sein, dass das funktioniert oder dass man diesen Aufwand treibt. Also vollautomatisch wird es auch nicht funktionieren, aber für eine kleinere Gruppe kann man es tun. Aber wenn man jetzt 20 oder 30 Millionen Leute hat, ist es auf jeden Fall erschwert, ist die ganze Geschichte. Ich gebe dir recht, dann müsste man tatsächlich einfach die anonyme GSM, das anonyme Mobilfunk, wobei da gibt es dann auch wieder den nächsten Ansatz, sicherlich Möglichkeiten, einfach komplett auf IP-Telefonie zu gehen. Und da gibt es dann durchaus, wenn das nicht von der Industrie verhindert wird, weil das nicht in die Businessmodelle passt, gäbe es durchaus Möglichkeiten, bereits vom Endgerät aus, einfach anonyme Kommunikation.
Ja, aber das ist ja alles Flickwerk. Das ist ja nichts für meine Eltern. Und meine Eltern betrifft es ja genauso.
Also wir sind halt jetzt gerade in dem Bereich technische Lösungen. Also sind wir in der Lage, technische Lösungen zu bauen, die uns zumindest über die dunklen Jahre tatsächlich den Handlungsspielraum erhalten. Also die Möglichkeit zu handeln, ohne dass wir halt in den ewigen Listen landen, die es halt irgendwann unmöglich machen, tatsächlich effektiv zu handeln. Und es ist schon so, dass es zumindest einen begrenzten Umfang Möglichkeiten gibt für Anonymizer und so weiter und so fort. Aber was es bedeutet, ist, dass wir in einem sehr großen Umfang politischen Aktivisten dieses technische Wissen zur Verfügung stellen müssen. Richtig. Ein sehr wichtiger Punkt ist, den Leuten, die einfach keine Ahnung davon haben, aber die Ideen haben, wie man diese Gesellschaft zum Positiven verändern kann und die halt einfach in diese ganzen Probleme reinlaufen, denen halt diese Wissen und diese Technologien zur Verfügung stellen und die halt auch für deine Eltern benutzbar machen.
Und da bist du eben an dem Knackpunkt, weil die meisten Menschen dann tatsächlich über das Stadium des einfachen Users gar nicht hinauskommen, auch gar nicht hinauskommen wollen, weil die eben vielleicht viel mehr damit beschäftigt sind, sich Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie man diese Gesellschaft positiv beeinflussen kann.
Weil sie extrem sind. Nein, das ist vielleicht nicht ihr Talent. Und sie haben vielleicht einfach eine andere Vorstellung davon, damit sie ihre Lebenszeit verbringen, was auf jeden Fall legitim ist. Nur ist es halt so, dass die Notwendigkeit, sich mit diesen technischen Detail zu beschäftigen, nimmt halt zu. Was passiert ist, selbst wenn man sich jetzt dagegen wehrt, wird die intellektuelle Bandbreite von Aktivisten zum Teil dadurch konsumiert, dass sie sich gegen diese allumfassende Erfassung irgendwie sich da rausmogeln müssen. Also der Aufwand. Ich kenne Leute, die in Umweltaktivistengruppen unterwegs sind. Die sagen, der Aufwand, den sie treiben müssen, um eine Aktion durchzuführen und durch die Maschen zu schnüpfen, ist jetzt schon signifikant höher geworden als vor 5 oder 6 Jahren. Da geht eine Menge Energie verloren, genau.
Und was wahrscheinlich auch die Strategie ist, weil das erhaltet sie hin. Dann werden sie müde.
Genau.
Das heißt also, technische Lösungen zu schaffen, die das durch die Maschenschnüpfen wieder bequem machen, ist denke ich mal einen Kernbereich unserer Aufgabe.
Gut, aber das Kämpfen Mühe macht, das werden wir nicht ganz verhindern können. Also wir können irgendwie den bequemen Kampf, werden wir sicherlich nicht organisieren können.
Vielleicht wenigstens die bequeme Kommunikation, um sich zum Kampf zu verabreden.
Ja, naja, gut, das...
Also, was wir halt klar sehen, ist, wir brauchen halt auf jeden Fall technische Lösungen. Da führt kein Weg drum herum. Wie die genau aussehen, können wir noch nicht sagen. Anonymizer ist sicherlich ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, wie Rob ganz richtig sagte. Wenn man in den Fokus von irgendeinem Interessegerät bis zum ersten Mal passiert, ist halt die Anonymisierung. Das ist halt das erste Ziel, rauskriegen, wer es wäre, weil dann kann man die Datenmachungen anschmeißen, gucken, wie können wir denen. Und das müssen halt nicht nur die staatlichen Datenmachungen sein. Das ist genauso bei Firmen genau das gleiche Spiel. Das andere, wo wir hier aber gerne noch sprechen möchten, ist, wir müssen es schaffen, diese Kultur zu kippen. Wir müssen es schaffen, dass Big Brother nicht cool ist. Wir müssen dahin kommen, dass diese Leute einfach mal blöde, böse Spanner sind. Und nicht Leute, die irgendwie cool sind, weil sie Macht haben.
Nein, und natürlich Leute, die einfach vielleicht mit guten Vorsätzen, aber einfach dabei sind, unsere Gesellschaft zu ruinieren. So, dass sie einfach als Gutmeinende, die meinen, irgendeine Ordnung und Sicherheit herzustellen und dabei faktisch das Gegenteil letztendlich erreichen.
Wie machst du denn der Masse klar? Das Problem ist doch, dass die Masse begreifen muss, oder zumindest der Teil der Masse, der die Deutungshoheit für sich reklamiert, dass diese Leute begreifen müssen, dass da was schief läuft. Und das begreifen sie ja nicht. Guck dir die Folterdebatte an, die wir vor einigen Monaten hatten. Das war das Absurdeste, was mir je in meinem Leben untergekommen ist in diesem Land. Und es gab Menschen, ganz normale Menschen, denen ich sogar einen hohen Grad an Intelligenz zubillige, die sich auf diese Diskussion eingelassen haben. Und dann mit völlig absurden Beispielen. Na ja, angenommen, wir würden einen Terroristen fassen, der wüsste, wo die Atombombe versteckt ist. Und wenn wir ihn nicht foltern, damit er das bekannt gibt, dann müssen 10.000 Menschen töten. Wer sowas diskutiert, der hat nicht mehr alle Tassen im Schrank.
Oder er guckt so viel 24.
Ja, wie auch immer.
Aber wer sowas diskutiert, der spinnt. Und anstatt solchen Leuten zu sagen, du spinnst, red mal keinen Scheiß, solch einen Fall gibt es einfach nicht. Stattdessen wird es diskutiert.
Bruce Schneier hat einen sehr schönen Begriff für Security Against Movie Plots.
Sicherheit nach Spielfilmhandlung.
Gegen Spielfilmszenarien.
Solange wir das noch nicht mal auf die Reihe kriegen, müssen wir noch viel früher anfangen. Ich lasse gerade mal sagen, wie die Sendung heißt. Chaosradio 110 in der Sendung... Guten Abend, Fighting the War.
Kriegst du das alles live?
Ich mache das live. Ich bin eine wandende Jingle-Maschine. Darf ich auch mal drücken? Ich vergingel dir den Podcast.
Eine Maßnahme. Fighting the War. Wenn man an der Kasse, was gelegentlich vorkommt, nach seiner Postleitzahl gefragt wird. Darf ich Ihre Postleitzahl erfahren? Nein. Dürfen Sie nicht.
Ich nehme immer die Postfach-Postleitzahl vom Rundfunk Berlin Brandenburg.
Es ist immer verblüffend, der Gesichtsausdruck. Aber mittlerweile scheinen die das auch zunehmend gewöhnt zu sein. Der Prozentsatz an Leuten, die einfach nicht bereit sind, Informationen preiszugeben, weil sie sonst vor allen Dingen gespammt oder von Leuten angerufen oder sonst wie belästigt werden, nimmt auch einfach zu.
Was ich sagen will, ist, dieser Kulturwandel, der fängt mit vielen kleinen Handlungen an. Ein Beispiel ganz positiv. Ich musste mir eine PriPet-Karte holen und hatte keine Zeit, auf den Flummer zu gehen. Also habe ich ganz normal in den nächstgelegenen Makromarkt gegangen. Und irgendwie, ich sagte einmal, PriPet wird irgendwie billig im Telefon dazu. War halt wirklich extrem billig. Und hatte mich jetzt schon darauf vorbereitet, erst mal die nächsten zehn Minuten damit zuzubringen, irgendwie diese ganzen, ich will Werbung haben, Paragraphen aus dem Vertrag zu streichen. Und bekomme den Vertrag ausgedruckt. Da waren nicht schon alle durchgestrichen. Alle, jeder Einzelne. Der Vertrag war in der Datenschutzoptimal-Konfiguration. Kam ja aus diesem System heraus. Pre-Washed. Sozusagen schon Pre-Washed, ja. Und ihr guckt den Verkäufer erstaunt an. Das ist aber schön, sage ich. Ich muss mich nicht in diesen ganzen Scheiß kümmern. Sagt er, wissen Sie, wir haben so viele Leute, die sich darüber aufregen. Wir machen es jetzt einfach immer so. Und sonst kommen die Leute irgendwie Monate später zu uns und sagen uns, ja, und wieso kriegt ihr denn hier diesen ganzen Werbemüll und diesen ganzen Scheiß? Deswegen sagt er, machen wir das jetzt einfach immer aus und drucken das immer aus. Das hat die Marktwertung so beschlossen.
Aber du bist immer noch verpflichtet, einen Namen und Adresse zu hinterlegen.
Das ist halt gesetzlicher Dienst.
Hörer dabei eigentlich?
Richie, bist du noch da?
Ich bin noch da und zwar, wir sitzen hier in der Runde und der James, der winkt mir gerade ganz fest und der möchte, glaube ich, auch noch was sagen. Darf ich euch den weiter reichen noch?
Ja, mach mal. Schau mal, wie weit ist denn der weg?
Ja, wir haben eine Verzögerung in der Leitung. Wir hören im Wohnzimmer. Wir sind so eine Gruppe und waren da auch gerade am diskutieren, an eurem Thema dran. Und wir sind jetzt gerade zu dem Punkt gekommen, ob das überhaupt Sinn macht, da eine große Revolte zu machen. Und sind eigentlich dadurch drauf gekommen, dass ihr eben gesagt habt, ihr habt euren Krieg verloren. Und der Richie, der vorhin drin war, der hat eine Umfrage gemacht. Nur so als Beispiel zu dem RFID-Chip. Ob die Leute da was dagegen hätten. Und es waren etwa 70% der Leute, die so nach dem Motto, mir ist doch egal, gesagt haben. Lasst doch mal machen und stört uns überhaupt nicht. Und dadurch sind wir eigentlich drauf gekommen, was ihr vorhin auch angesprochen habt, so ganz kurz aber nur gestreift. Die Masse zu bewegen, ist das überhaupt möglich? Und wir sind der Meinung, einfach jetzt aus der Erfahrung, aus der Beobachtung dieser Gesellschaft, die sich jetzt zusammensetzt, aus Fun-Leuten, Ignoranten, Mitläufern, und ich bin reich und mir kann sowieso keiner was und so weiter. Das ist hier so typisch, die Einstellung in Deutschland. Dann sind wir zu dem Schluss gekommen, dass man die Masse nicht mehr bewegen kann. Weil die Masse bestimmte Dinge auch gar nicht mehr versteht. .einer sprachlichen Auffassungsgabe, gar nicht Intelligenz. Da mag vielleicht einer dabei sein, der einen ganz geringen Wortschatz hat, oder der wunderschöne Bilder malen kann. Der kann sich auf diese Weise kommunikativ bewegen. Aber er ist einfach nicht in der Lage, sprachlich die Dinge korrekt wahrzunehmen.
James, ich glaube, das Problem, was du meinst, ist eher, dass die Masse stets unvernünftig sein wird. Aber zu bewegen ist sie doch. Nein, genau das ist es nicht mehr. Mit hinreichend finanzieller Ausstattung bin ich doch in der Lage, jede beliebige Masse in jede beliebige Richtung zu bewegen. Ja. Ich bin nur nicht in der Lage, sie zu einem vernünftig handelnden Einzelwesen oder zu einem Souverän zu machen.
Man muss dazu vielleicht noch eines sagen. Auch Dummheit ist in einer Demokratie ein Recht.
Und das scheint mir, dass das viele eben wahrnehmen, wenn man das mal so ausdrücken. Aber noch mal zu dem Punkt. Ich finde, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, dass ich der Meinung bin, dass diese Leute in Wirklichkeit nicht dumm sind im Sinn von Intellekt. Die tun das auch. Aber mein Beispiel, vielleicht dieser War-A und A-Mann und Cool-Man, der nicht viel mehr Worte zusammenbringt, zu Hause aber die schönsten Bilder malt, ich finde, das ist ein hoher Intellekt. Er hat einfach nur die Sprache verloren. Und das Problem ist bei uns, die Masse zu bewegen, das geht eben über Werbung, über Information, also über Sprache. Und nicht über Bilder, wie dieser eine das vielleicht verstehen würde. Und das ist für mich das Ding, wenn man sich mit solchen Leuten, die eine scheinbar geringe Bildung haben, unterhält, findet man bei jedem so ein kleines Goldstück, wo man sagen kann, Mensch, das ist eigentlich ein Mensch, der ist was wert, der hat ein Intellekt. Er ist nur nicht in der Lage, solche Worte, wie ich sie jetzt spreche oder wie ihr sie diskutiert, aufzufassen und zu verstehen. Der hört eure Sendung vielleicht eine Minute in der Schalte, der Abfall das einfach nicht mehr kapiert.
Darf ich mal interrompieren? Reden von der Masse ist immer so ein bisschen schwierig. Diese Debatte und diese Kritik, die du an die Masse hast, ist eigentlich von alle Zeiten. So definiert, wie du es definiert hast, hat die Masse noch nie was verstanden. Die Welt ist auch noch nie von der Masse geändert. Die Welt ist immer geändert von so 1, 2, 3 %. Das ist auch nicht schlimm. Nur diese 1, 2, 3 % hat es wohl mal gebraucht, sich in diese restlichen 97 % zu verstecken. Und wenn diese 3 % einfach aus dem Data Mining rausfallen, und das ist wohl neu, und das hat wohl kein Präzident, dann haben wir ein Problem. Also es ist interessant, zu reden von Masse, zu reden von wie bewegen wir die Masse, aber das gab es immer schon.
Also der Punkt ist letzten Endes, wenn du dir anguckst, wer tatsächlich die Handelnden in einer Gesellschaft sind, also die tatsächlich ihr Recht auf Handlung wahrnehmen, worum es halt gehen muss für uns, ist, diesen Leuten die Handlung frei zu erhalten. Das denke ich mal der Kern dabei. Ob jetzt irgendwie dazu gehört, den Bildzeitungslesern zu vermitteln, dass Sicherheit vielleicht nicht das alleinige glückselig machende ist, ist dann sozusagen nur ein technischer Teil dabei. Worum es halt geht, ist, die Handlungsfähigkeit und die Veränderungsfähigkeit der Gesellschaft zu erhalten. Das heißt, dafür zu sorgen, dass wir diese Gesellschaft überhaupt noch verändern können. Weil wenn die Regeln und die Gesetze und die kleinen Verordnungen und die kleinen Verstöße halt alle mal in Computercode gegossen sind, dann wird es halt furchtbar anstrengend.
Aber es gibt, um auch mal wieder ihr was Positives reinzubringen, es ist ja nicht nur so, dass die ganze neue Technologie nur zur Überwachung genutzt werden kann, sondern sie kann natürlich auch, sie bietet ganz neue Möglichkeiten für Terroristen, aber auch ganz neue Möglichkeiten für uns alle, uns zu verständigen, auszutauschen, miteinander zu kommunizieren. Also Beispiel Blogs oder Podcasting, wo jeder einfach mal seine Meinung auch zu irgendwelchen Dingen raus tun kann und auch die direkte Meinung anderer dort erfahren oder nachlesen kann auf eine ganz andere Art. Und das gerade das Blog-Phänomen hat sich doch als durchaus mächtig gezeigt, wo sich auch die Blogs durchaus Kontrolle und Zensur entzogen haben, wo man sich auch international durchaus ausweichen kann. Ich gebe zu, auch diese Freiräume sind natürlich in Gefahr, aber im Moment scheint es doch so zu sein, dass die neuen Medien und die neue Vernetzung doch immer noch ein Stückchen schneller laufen bisher als die Unterdrückung.
Naja, der Nachteil an Blogs ist, auch die landen im ewigen Archiv. Da ist also auch die landen in der ewigen Liste. Und was Peter vorhin sagte, das Recht auf Vergessen und Vergebung gibt es im Internet de facto nicht. Das existiert eigentlich nicht. Es gibt keine technische Lösung für das Vergessen. Ein bisschen drastisch. Deswegen haben diese Blogs natürlich auch diese Kehrseite, dass man sich schon genau überlegen muss, was man da reintut. Und jeder geht damit irgendwie anders um. Und viele Leute bloggen auch tatsächlich anonym aus genau diesem Grund. Was auch sehr wichtig ist, dass sie das tun können. Aber es zeigt eben auch, dass eben nur durch die Anonymität Dinge möglich sind. Wenn diese Anonymität zum Beispiel durch diese Vorratsdatenspeicherung halt extrem leicht ausgehebelt werden kann, weil du halt einfach mal direkt gucken kannst, von welcher IP-Adresse wurde denn dieses Blog modifiziert, und zwar irgendwie noch sechs Monate zurück oder noch länger, dann wird die Freiheit halt auch wieder eingeschränkt.
James, ich würde gerne mal Danke sagen und die nächsten Anrufer noch so rannehmen. Danke für eure Anrufe. Und da war nämlich noch Tim.
Peter, hattest du nicht auch noch so einen Fall vorhin angesprochen mit der ewigen Liste? Der Radikalfall?
Ach ja, genau. Naja, es gibt sehr viele Beispiele. Es gab ein Beispiel aus den Staaten, wo jemand, der in der Zwischenzeit ins Berufsleben gekommen war, aus seiner Studentenzeit, die noch nicht zu lange zurückliegt, erzählt hat, in der er gern und freigiebig Petitionen unterschrieben hat für Dinge, von denen er durchaus überzeugt war oder gegen die er war, bis er festgestellt hat, dass diese Petitionen sozusagen auf jetzt und ewig die elektronisch stattgefunden haben, irgendwo im Internet archiviert sind und mit Automaten wie der Wayback Machine jederzeit wieder rausgeholt werden können. In der Zwischenzeit hat er große Sorge, dass ein Arbeitgeber oder ein zukünftiger Arbeitgeber irgendwann mal eine kleine Recherche im Netz machen könnte und auf Dinge stößt, die für ihn schon in seiner Vergangenheit liegen. Er sieht sich selber schon als jemanden, der Erfahrungen gemacht hat, gelernt hat, woanders ist und ist in der Zwischenzeit ein unpolitischerer Mensch geworden als Vorsicht. Er ist vorsichtig geworden, weil er gesehen hat, dass politische Äußerungen, die ja auch immer so Momentaufnahmen einer bestimmten Lebensphase sind, im Internet durch diese Totalspeicherung auf ewig festgehalten werden. Ein anderes Beispiel war jemand hier aus Deutschland, der in den 80er Jahren, da gab es die Zeitschrift Radikal, auch in Papierform, die gab es dann nachher noch lange in elektronischer Form, die, weil sie tatsächlich ihren Titel auch eingelöst hat, zum Teil inhaltlich versucht hat, das Risiko, dass jede Ausgabe beschlagen und wird, etwas zu streuen, indem im Impressum nicht eine Person als VSTB stattgefunden hat, sondern dass eine größere Gruppe von Leuten war. Und aus dieser Gruppe wurden dann aber unglücklicherweise ein paar Leute herausgepickt, die dann, also sozusagen stellvertretend, denen der Prozess gemacht werden sollte. Und es war zu einer Zeit, damals waren die Grünen noch jung und frisch und neu gegründet, dass die Grünen einen der Leute, die da angeklagt worden sind als Mitherausgeber der Zeitschutzradikale, auf sehr elegante Art und Weise in Schutz genommen haben, indem sie ihn nämlich nominiert haben als ihren Kandidaten für das Europaparlament. Der ist dann auch tatsächlich nach Straßburg gegangen und hatte als Parlamentarier. Immunität konnte auch nicht, der Prozess konnte nicht stattfinden. Und vier Jahre später, nachdem dieses Mandat abgelaufen war, hatten sich die Zeitläufe auch so geändert, dass es sozusagen gar nicht mehr, der Prozess hat nicht stattgefunden. Also das war eine Lösung. Was heute immer noch passiert ist, wenn dieser Mann, der in der Zwischenzeit als Gentechnikkritiker Kongresse auf der ganzen Welt besucht, im Auftrag von Stiftungen, die an diesem Thema auf kritische Art und Weise interessiert sind, passiert es ihm immer wieder, dass seine Kontrahenten, seine Widersacher, die Leute auf der anderen Seite ausgezeichnet informiert sind sofort über seine Vergangenheit, weil das alles im Internet dokumentiert ist und nicht verschwindet, nicht verschwinden wird. Was dadurch in Gefahr gerät, ist so ein Gedanke wie zum Beispiel Resozialisierung.
Also bei mir muss ich sagen, hat das Ganze, die ganze politische Entwicklung einen gegenteiligen Effekt gehabt. Ich habe mich früher eher auch bedeckt gehalten, gerade was Petitionen unterzeichnen angeht oder mich politisch zu exponieren, weil ich tatsächlich auch doch durchaus eine vielleicht eher unbegründete Befürchtung hatte. Aber die war schon da. Wer weiß, wer mir da irgendwann einen Strick draus dreht. Also ich war da, gehörte dann eher zu den etwas übervorsichtigen Leuten. Allerdings ist meine Empörung über viele Dinge jetzt so groß geworden, dass mir das jetzt einfach schlichtweg egal ist. Ich sage, ich muss mich da äußern, ich werde mich da äußern und ich stehe einfach dazu. Also ich kann nicht anders. Das heißt, ich hoffe natürlich, dass es auch mehr Leute gibt, denen es so geht, das ab einem bestimmten Punkt einfach man sagt, man erträgt es nicht. Und die Konsequenzen sind mir jetzt egal, aber ich muss und werde was dagegen tun.
Das bedingt in unserer Welt allerdings eine gewisse finanzielle Unabhängigkeit.
Oder zumindest den Willen, nicht zwingend in Institutionen arbeiten zu wollen, die solchen Kriterien Vorschub leisten.
Du kannst es ja nicht wissen, ob du es tust. Letztendlich sind die öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunkanstalten die Horte der Demokratie, die vierte Macht im Staate. Und ich bin nicht in der Lage, meine Kritik an ihnen offen so zu formulieren, wie ich sie eigentlich formulieren wollen würde. Von daher, da funktioniert es schon wieder nicht mehr.
Also solange es noch Chaosradio gibt, ist es auf jeden Fall ein gutes Zeichen, was wir hier schon teilweise abgelassen haben in einzelnen Runden. Das war jetzt nicht immer staatskonform.
Ja gut, ich meine, Meinungsfreiheit schadet so einem Staat ja in der Regel halt auch nicht so. Also ich meine, die Abwesenheit von Meinungsfreiheit schadet so einem Staat halt irgendwie wesentlich mehr als irgendwie Meinungsfreiheit an sich. Das ist sicherlich auch eine Sache, die die meisten Politiker nicht bestreiten werden, außer wenn gerade über sie vom Leder gezogen wird. Aber es sind dann meistens nur temporäre Erscheinungen. Aber der tatsächliche Meinungsfreiheit bzw. das Benutzen der Meinungsfreiheit ist ja nur ein Aspekt von tatsächlich Widerstand gegen eine Gesellschaft, in der man halt nicht mehr tun und lassen kann, was man möchte. Und wie gesagt, diese Freiwilligkeit, diese Teilnahme an, sei es irgendwelche beschissenen Rabatt- und Bonusprogramme, die halt... Also ich meine, nehmen wir mal Kaufhof. Ich meine, ich gehe da nicht mehr hin, weil ich das nicht mehr hören kann. Haben die eine Galerie? Kaufhof, können wir taten?
Habe ich mich neulich im Car-Shut mit einer Verkäuferin darüber und habe auch gesagt, geht ihnen das nicht unfassbar auf die Nerven, jeden blöd Mann zu fragen, ob er irgendwie so eine Rabatt gattet. Ja, aber was will ich machen, wenn ich nicht frage, fliege ich raus?
Ich gehe da nicht mehr hin. Ich gehe da genau nicht mehr hin. Ich parkortiere die, weil ich diesem Unsinn, diese Datenerfassung, ich habe mich da schon mehrere Mal darüber aufgeregt irgendwie, dass die mir dann auch noch diese Anträge andrehen wollen und wollen sie denn nicht. Und ich gehe da schlicht nicht mehr hin. Ich parkortiere Unternehmen offensiv, die halt solche Datenerfassungen betreiben. Und ich finde, das irgendwie auch mal...
Wo willst du denn dann noch einkaufen gehen? Ja, dann gehst du nur noch zu Lidl, die beuten ihre Leute aus. Also das sind...
Nee, da gibt es immer noch Alternativen.
Was du machen kannst natürlich mit der Karte, ich glaube, du, Chris, wenn du sie dir ausstellen lässt, kriegst du einmal, ich glaube, ich 5 Prozent an dem Tag für diesen entsprechenden Einkauf. Das war, was ich einmal gemacht hatte, halt...
Sprich mal ins Mikrofon, bitte.
Also, ja, 5 Prozent auf das Laptop meiner Frau und dann die Karte halt gleich zerschnitten und weggeworfen.
Es gab doch mal früher so ein experimentelles Verfahren, wo man dort, wo der Magnetstreifen, ein Stück Sandpapier aufkleben konnte.
Ich meine, es ist wirklich frapierend. Wir müssen wirklich zurückgehen irgendwie in die Mitte der 80er und gucken, was haben sich die Leute damals ausgedacht, als irgendwie all die ganzen Dinge, die wir heute haben, noch so eine utropische Dystopie im Horizont waren. Also da müssen wir einfach mal zurückgehen, die euch nicht verkaufen.
Noch mal einen Kopf aufmachen und nochmal, ja, nachdenken.
Viele von den Gedanken, die uns heute sozusagen bewegen wurden, damals hat schon gedacht, nur damals war halt ein, was wäre wenn und heute ist es irgendwie nicht mehr wenn, sondern wann.
Na gut, aber ich meine, einige Dinge tun wir auch im Club in die Richtung, so Überwindungssicherheit von Biometrie beispielsweise. Das ist auf jeden Fall ein gutes Thema, wo man schön mitspielen kann. Selber mal lernen. Ich meine, der Club hat ja auch eine Anleitung, wie mache ich mir fremde Fingerabdrücke beispielsweise. Das macht Spaß.
Kann man auch schön in der Kita machen.
Ja, es ist nett, denn vielleicht könnte man Schminkkurse geben, um halt so den...
Ich sehe schon so Kinderspielzeugkisten. So der kleine Hacker.
Für Fünfjährige.
Dann natürlich grundsätzlich Platten verschlüsseln. Okay, Platten verschlüsseln ist alles und überall möglich. Man sollte eigentlich keine unverschlüsselte Festplatte auf irgendeinem Rechner überhaupt haben, weil man weiß nie...
Warum sollte ich das nicht haben?
Naja, weil wenn du dein Laptop, falls du eins hast, zum Beispiel im Taxi vergisst, ist das schon mal ganz schlecht. Aber noch schlechter ist es, falls du irgendwann durch Zufall irgendjemand dieselbe IP-Adresse wie du gehabt hat im DSL und der ist halt ein bekannter Sauger, aber bei der Datenerfassung gibt es halt einen Unsicherheitszeitraum. Das heißt, du kannst versehentlich auch für jemand anderen gehalten werden. Wenn du die IP-Adresse kriegst, da gibt es so ungefähr eine Minute, da ist es halt nicht genau. Und dann kann es passieren, dass weil du von irgendwelchen Rechteverwertern dann automatisch aus der Datenbank rausgefallen bist, Plötzlich halt bei dir dein Rechner zu Hause beschlagnahmt wird und blöderweise hast du halt irgendwelche Musikstücke drauf, deren Herkunft oder Filme, deren Herkunft du nicht ganz klar eindeutig belegen kannst oder vielleicht Software.
Was du gerade sagst ist, ich sollte meine Festplatte verschlüsseln, damit die Sachen, die ich illegalerweise in meinen Besitz gebracht habe, nicht mir, nicht dir zu lassen.
Damit du dein Recht auf Privatkopie noch wahrnehmen kannst. Das ist nämlich genau der Punkt.
Wenn ich mein Recht auf Privatkopie wahrnehme, dann bin ich aber auch in der Lage, nachzuvollziehen, woher ich das Original habe.
Ach, dann kommen die anderen und wollen das Original-CD-Cover sehen. Und das hast du dann nicht mehr, weil du gedacht hast, Scheiß-CD-Cover jedes Mal umziehen.
Also der Punkt ist halt, worum es geht, ist tatsächlich Daten-Selbstverteidigung.
Ja, also ich frage, warum sollte ich das machen? Also erklär das mal jemandem, der vielleicht ein Laptop hat, aber nie mit einem Taxi unterwegs ist, nie solche Sachen runterlädt.
Also grundsätzlich, ich meine, das ist halt ganz einfach. So ein Geschäftsführer, der handelt fahrlässig, wenn er seine Unternehmensdaten unterschiedlich mit sich rumträgt. Ganz einfach. Wenn du irgendwie deine Daten, vor allem, dass ich mit dir rumträge, riskierst du, dass irgendwie übermorgen eine DVD auf dem Flohmarkt zu haben, ist Holgies Pawn Collection schon sein Notebook. Das heißt, das Risiko, dass deine Daten verloren gehen, ist groß. Und sei es nun irgendwie die Content-Mafia, oder sei es irgendwer, der da des Weges kommt und auf deine Platte will, eigentlich hat er kein Recht dazu. Also aus deinem Bauchgefühl heraus hat eigentlich niemand ein Recht, auf deiner Platte zu stören, oder? Also musst du dafür sorgen, dass das nicht passieren kann. Ganz einfach. Datenselbstverteidigung.
Ja, aber meine Maschine steht ja zu Hause.
Ja, wie gesagt, die Möglichkeit, dass dort die Staatsmacht einmarschiert. Hast du gerade nachgeguckt? Genau, hast du gerade nachgeguckt, ob sie doch wirklich dort steht.
Okay, Treffer, Punkt für dich.
Verschlüsselung überall verwenden ist sicherlich einer der Kernpunkte.
Gibt es das in Clickybunti?
Gibt es das in Clickybunti. Für alles hoch und runter installiere ich mich. Es gibt halt irgendwie gute und schlechte Verschlüsselung, aber Verschlüsselung ist gar keine Verschlüsselung. Der Kernpunkt ist, außer Verschlüsselung brauchen wir auch Anonymität. Es gibt zumindest für das Internet verschiedene Anonymizer, zum Beispiel Tor oder YAP, die deinen Datenverkehr, wo der herkommt und wo der hingeht, dadurch verschleiern, dass er den Datenverkehr von vielen anderen Leuten an einem sogenannten Mixnode vermischt. Idealerweise mit mehreren Mixnodes. Man kann sich so vorstellen, der ganze Verkehr wird an einen großen Mixer gebracht, da wird er durchgerührt, dann geht er zum nächsten Mixer, wird da wieder durchgerührt und dann geht er da raus. Zwischendurch ist alles ordentlich verschlüsselt, sodass man nicht sagen kann, welches Datenpaket gehört zu wem. Die gibt es mittlerweile in recht einfach zu installieren. Tim, können wir mal die entsprechenden URLs auf die Wikid-Seite tun? Für Jap und Tor.
Wenn die nicht schon da sind.
Ah genau, wahrscheinlich stehen sie sogar schon drauf. Die sind wirklich recht einfach runterzuladen. Zum zahlen gibt es Cross-Plattformen für alles. Nachteil ist, dass es teilweise ziemlich langsam zu benutzen ist. Das heißt, wenn man zum normalen Browsen, Chatten, Surfen benutzen will, kann es sein, dass es auch mal erheblich ruckelt, weil viele Leute es mittlerweile benutzen. Der Bedarf ist groß. Es sind Non-Profit-Systeme, die nicht so viele Server haben und so viel Bandbreite haben, wie sie eigentlich haben sollten.
Ein anderes Ding ist die Benutzung von Suchmaschinen. Dass man sich da in Acht nimmt, weil wenn sich jeder, der dort sitzt, vorstellt, dass irgendjemand über eine Liste sämtlicher Suchanfragen, sämtlicher Schlüsselworte, die du in den letzten zwei Jahren gemacht hast, verfügt, ist das ein angenehmer Gedanke?
Allein schon den ganzen Krempel, den man da zum Spaß nur reinschreibt. Wenn einem das irgendwann mal ernst genommen wird, wird es böse.
Man hat ja in vielen Branchen diese Google-Suchinstruktion. Wenn man auf dieses kleine Fällchen links klickt, sieht man die letzten 20 oder so. Da weiß man schon, wonach du gesucht hast.
Und Google hat sie natürlich alle. Immer noch sind Google scheinbar die Guten zu sein. Aber es gibt einen Haufen Probleme. Einmal die Suchabfragen, die über Cookies eindeutig zugeordnet werden können, über längere Zeit dann die Verknüpfung mit Google Mail, wo dein dazugehöriger Mailverkehr noch angesehen werden kann. Verknüpfung mit Orkut. Und in der Verknüpfung über Orkut dann auch noch deine ganzen Freunde und Freundschaftsverhältnisse. Da zieht man sich dann schon, ohne es vielleicht zu merken, ganz schön aus an der Stelle plötzlich. Ich meine, noch kämpft Google ja dagegen, die Daten rauszugeben.
Jetzt wollen sie das einfach löschen.
Ja, was heißt rausgeben? Wenn man die End-User-License sagt, hat man ja sogar kein eigenes Recht daran. Bei Orkut war das zum Beispiel so.
Also eine Empfehlung, es gibt Browser, bei denen man einstellen kann, dass man Cookies von bestimmten Seiten nicht gesetzt haben möchte. Und es ist sehr empfehlenswert, da Stern Google, Stern einzugeben, um halt von keiner und die anderen Suchmaschinen, die ihr benutzt, um halt von diesen Suchmaschinen genau keine Cookies gespeichert zu bekommen. Durchaus sehr. Also einige Browser haben noch mal so einen extra Private Browsing Mode, wo sie halt keine Cookies annehmen und so weiter und so fort und halt irgendwie auch verschleiern, mit welchem Browser und von welcher Art Betriebssystem irgendwie diese Anfrage kommt. Wenn man das hat, kann man natürlich auch benutzen. Ich benutze vier verschiedene Browser, je nachdem, was ich gerade tue.
Da wird es ja schon wieder kompliziert.
Ja, gut, ich gebe aber zu, das ist nichts, was ich empfehlen würde. Ich würde empfehlen, irgendwie einen Firefox oder Mozilla oder ähnlichen oder Firebird zu nehmen. Also einen dieser Browser, die aus einer Open-Source-Familie kommen und die auch entsprechende Konfigurationsoptionen, die auch einfach genug zu finden sind, verfügen.
Wir haben noch einen Anrufer, der bespringt dir, glaube ich, bei. Der ist nämlich pessimist. Elia Heister, grüß dich.
Hallo, guten Abend. Ja, gut, was soll ich sagen?
Du hast angerufen, du solltest wissen, was du sagen solltest.
Sag einfach die Wahrheit.
Gib's zu.
Wir wissen es ja eh schon.
Also ganz ehrlich sein, ja? Natürlich. Wir wissen, dass jetzt sozusagen die Grenze erreicht ist. Seitdem ich lebe, merke ich, dass dieses Thema oder was auch immer das ist. Oder dieser Staat. Kann das sein?
Bitte was? Ja, das kann sein, dass es den Staat gibt, seitdem du lebst.
Ja und im jeden Fall dieses Etwas belässt sich irgendwie nicht nur mich, sondern meine Freunde, meinen Verwandtenkreis und jeden, den ich kenne.
Und auf welche Weise tut es das?
Wie alles. So fängt das schon bei Hartz IV an. Wenn man Hartz IV empfängt hat das ja. Dann kriegt man zum Beispiel, also dann, keine Ahnung, warum auf einmal. Das war Manken? Warum? Was?
Nee, ich bin an die Jingle-Maschine gekommen.
Entschuldigung.
Ich wollte die Sendung nicht unterbrechen. Wie auch immer. Jedenfalls weiß ich ganz genau, dass das alles nicht so ganz gut ist. Wenn die Leute Hartz-IV-Empfänger sind und dass ihnen ihr ganzes, aspartes Geld weggenommen wird. Was vielleicht irgendwann mal in ihrem Leben eine wichtige Rolle spielen würde oder weiß ich was. Und was bei vielen Leuten halt passiert so. Was ja auch der Alltag ist. Aber woher wissen die, dass das Geld da ist? Das dürfen die doch eigentlich gar nicht sehen.
Ja, dann ist das einfach nur ungeschickt versteckt geworden.
Ja, aber guck mal, wir sind ganz normale Bürger. Weißt du, wir gehen doch gar nicht ganz zu meiner ganz normalen Bank. Und die Leute können doch nichts dafür, dass ihr Geld auf einmal weg ist. Es wurde einfach abgebucht. Weil man als Hartz-IV-Empfänger ja keine eigenen Geldzahl was besitzen darf.
Aber dann muss man, also ich kenne nun auch eine ganze Menge an Leuten, die davon betroffen sind. Und die haben teilweise auch, also es gab ja eine ganze Menge Beratungsstellen. Und da wurde halt auch mehr oder weniger offen dazu geraten oder Ratschläge gegeben, wie man halt tatsächlich sich noch seinen Notgroschen irgendwo in Sicherheit bringen kann. Und ich kenne nun eine ganze Menge Leute, die das auch dann einfach getan haben, von in Bar unter die Matratze legen, bis halt als beliebtestes Mittel jemanden zu fragen, der noch Einkommen hat, vertrauenswürdig ist und halt ihnen dann ein Konto auf seinen Namen anlegen lassen. Das war dann oft so der Ausweg. Aber es gibt noch 20, 30 andere Mittel. Also es gibt ja nun ja.
Nö. Ich sag schon jedes Mal hier, wenn irgendwo so ein Zufried mit einer Kamera rumrennt, einfach die Kamera kaputt machen, wenn er ein Foto von mir macht. Ich kann darauf echt verzichten. Ich hab keinen Bock mehr. Ich will einfach ganz normal leben und ich will nicht, dass das mein Leben oder irgendein sonstiges Leben von irgendwelchen Leuten.
Das Problem ist, Elia, das darfst du nicht uns sagen. Das muss du, erzählst du deinem Abgeordneten.
Ja, aber du darfst es aber auch nicht so weit kommen.
Dann müsst ihr doch mal sehen, dass das alles sowieso, dass es sinnlos ist. Wir müssen einfach jetzt so aufstehen. Das hat keinen Zweck mehr. Und ich, alles. Das ist einfach so Freiheit, man.
Ja, aber vor allem, ja, ich meine, muss natürlich auch... Angst, kann ich dir sagen, hilft dir schon mal gar nicht weiter. Also Angst lähmt dich und wenn du gelähmt bist, dann hast du sowieso keine Chance. Von daher musst du das Ganze proaktiv umdrehen und einfach mal ganz konkret analysieren, was dich stört und dann schrittweise vorgehen, um das Ganze von dir fernzuhalten.
Also ich sag mal jetzt so, es gibt ja viele Leute, die auch versucht haben, da was gegen zu unternehmen, ja. Seit jetzt, sag ich, Chaos, also hier Computerklub sowieso schon immer eigentlich, ja. Für Datenschutz und bla bla bla. Obwohl ich das manchmal auch nicht so ganz glauben kann alles, aber das hört sich für mich toll an und ich bin da auch voll auf eurer Seite. Aber ich weiß nicht, das ist doch das letzte, dass man sich mit so einer Organisation so weit durch, oder dass man sich da überhaupt irgendwas erkämpfen muss, weil man einfach das Recht dafür hat, muss man sich da irgendwas erkämpfen, was da inne steht.
Ja, weil das das das das Wesentliche Demokratie ist, dass sie nicht selbstverständlich ist.
Ja, weil das ist, also lasst uns das jetzt sagen.
Also solange die Leute im Wesentlichen zu Hause sitzen, die Füße hochlegen und sich denken, na jetzt haben wir ja Demokratie.
Ja, ich bin auch zu Hause und spiele Computer, verstehst du mein Computer? Da machst du eine Fehlermeldung, ich raste Ausweise und so. Und ich ruf hier an und sage, dass mir auf den Sack geht, dass alles so runter ins Berg abgeht. Und das interessiert auch alle.
Das ist auch echt super, wenn du dich entröstest. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal der erste Schritt, der wichtige Schritt zu sagen, ey mir stinkt's. Ich finde das scheiße und das jedem zu erzählen, der es hören will oder auch nicht. Das ist schon mal der erste gute Schritt.
Schreiben sie ihrem Abgeordneten, finde ich immer wieder schön. Einfach mal hingehen. Bei mir im Bezirk ist das Ströbele. Einfach mal in die Sprechstunde gehen. Und dem einfach mal so lange auf den Keks gehen, bis er dich rausschmeißt.
Bitte was?
Ja warum? Nee, kriegst du aber nicht. Die Zeiten ändern sich.
Wir machen jetzt Nachrichten.
Ich verstehe nur Bügeleisen.
Das ist das Überste Krasse, was ich jemals in meinem Leben erlebt habe. Also ich weiß nicht, was das soll. Ich finde das eine Frechheit. Und alles geschieht es. Alles geschieht es. Auf der ganzen Welt.
Super, ich würde sagen, die Botschaft ist rüber gekommen.
Danke Elia.
Ihr Einsatzgebiet Berlin und Brandenburg. Ihr Auftrag Fritzmusik. Musik zum Tanzen.
Vom RBB.
Fünfeinhalb eins.
Nachrichten. Der Unsicherheitsrat hat den Sprengstoffanschlag auf die Goldene Moschee im irakischen Samaraschlaf verurteilt. Nach dem Anschlag auf das schiitische Heiligtum gingen landesweit zionitische Moschee in Flammen auf. In Bagdad wurden 20 Terrorverdächtige von Bewaffneten aus einem Gefängnis geholt und in den Straßen der Hauptstadt getötet. Der Bundesnachrichtendienst soll im Irak doch Angaben über militärische Ziele an US-Ställen weitergegeben haben. Wie Grünen Vize-Fraktionschef Ströbele im RBB Hörfunk erklärte, hat die Arbeit des Parlamentarischen Kontrollgremiums entsprechende Hinweise erbracht. Die Gewerkschaft Verdi will die Streit zum öffentlichen Dienst in den kommenden Tagen noch ausweiten. Das kündigte der Bundesvorsitzende Bzirske an. Die Beschäftigten wehren sich gegen die geplante Verlängerung der waffentren Arbeitszeit auf 40 Stunden. In England haben als Polizisten verkleidete Gangster umgerechnet mindestens 37 Millionen Euro erbeutet. Damit handelt es sich um den vermutlich größten Raubüberfall in der britischen Kriminalgeschichte. Die sechs Täter hatten ein Depot für Wertgegenstände in der Grafschaft Kent überfallen. Und noch zum Sport. Werder Bremen hat in der Fußball-Champions League sein Achtelfinal-Hinspiel in letzter Minute gewonnen. Die Rehmer schlugen am Abend auf eigenen Platz Juventus Turin mit 3 zu 2. In dieser Nachtstadt bewölkt überwiegend trocken zum Morgen im Norden etwas Schnee möglich bei Tiefstwerten zwischen minus zwei und minus fünf Grad. Am Tag dann in der Uckermark und in der Prignitz leichter Schneefall. Ansonsten Wolken und weitgehend trocken bei Höchstwerten zwischen null und zwei Grad plus. Wir haben keine Meldungen. Der Verkehr rollt. Gute Fahrt.
Vielen Dank, Matthias Karkow, sieben Minuten nach halb eins.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz in Eberswalde.
Und zwar Chaosradio 110, die Datenpolizeisendung.
Ja, der Stichwort Polizei.
Ich muss schon diesen Nachrichten...
Hammer, oder? Hammer!
Also ich muss da gerade nochmal drauf eingehen auf diese 37 Millionen Pfund.
Nein, Euro, 25 Millionen Pfund.
Ja, irgendwie als Polizisten verkleidet. Das ist auch super. Das erinnert mich an diesen, wie war denn dieser Bankraub mit diesen Typen, der, genau in Frankreich gab es so eine ähnliche Geschichte, dass jemand zu einem Bankraub gesagt hat, er ist bei so einer ganz geheimen Anti-Terror-Einheit und hat sich dann auch vorher telefonisch akkreditieren lassen und hat so eine ganze Geschichte gesponnen, um sozusagen den Eindruck zu ermitteln, irgendwie im Rahmen einer ganz geheimen Anti-Terror-Operation müssen jetzt mal da so eine halbe Million Euro irgendwie von da nach da bewegt werden. Und hat halt als extrem glaubwürdig aufgebaut und, ja, und wie gut ist Ministerpräsidenten, stellen sich mal keine Fragen dazu. Und hat das dann am Schluss wirklich mit einer substanziellen Menge, wirklich sechs oder siebenstellig Euro davon geschlichen. Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie ihn gekriegt haben, aber ich glaube, solche Dinge werden sich häufen, dass sozusagen unter dem Mantel von Sicherheitsbehörden, Geheimaktionen, diese Dinge. Ja gut, ich meine, wenn jetzt Geldtransporte unternehmen, ja schon.
Genau, Geldtransporte.
Nö, das ist ein Geld von fünf Euro kräftig.
Genau, also ich meine, es scheint ja offensichtlich organisiert gewesen zu sein. Ich meine, also besser kann man irgendwie dieses Problem mit diesem Sicherheitsapparat nicht illustrieren, ja. Er funktioniert einfach nicht.
Jetzt haben wir noch 20 Minuten. Jetzt würde ich mal auch vorschlagen, dass wir vielleicht noch mal so ein bisschen in die Zukunft blicken.
Genau, wo sind die 300 Millionen her? Also es müssen alles Schwarzgelder gewesen sein, die 300 Millionen, die sie an die Seite... Weil keiner keinem fehlen irgendwie 300 Millionen. Oder hat sich schon jemand gemeldet?
Ich glaube, für 60 Millionen haben sie schon Eigentümer, aber der Rest ist...
Aber 240, ich frage mich auch, woher sie so genau wussten, dass es sich um 300 Millionen handelt. Das ist mir auch ein Rätsel.
Wie funktioniert denn so eine Maschine? Die Zukunft.
Rob, bist du noch da?
Ach so, warte mal. Rob, muss ich noch wieder einschalten hier. Dann hatte ich für die Nachrichten ausgedacht. Hallo Rob.
Ja, Zukunft. Ich glaube, Frank und ich haben mit diesem Ding auf dem Kongress erst mal gemeint, die Leute klar zu machen, dass sich was fundamental geändert hat in den letzten paar Jahren. Und dass wir jetzt eine neue Situation haben. Und dass wir bitte alle mal über die Zukunft nachdenken müssen. Wir haben eigentlich nie behauptet, wir wissen da, was die Zukunft, was wir machen können, was wir noch machen sollen. Sondern erst mal realisieren, dass da ein Problem ist. Ja, Zukunft.
Gibt es denn noch Horte der Freiheit eigentlich? So Länder, wo man vielleicht hingehen...
Der Punkt mit Freiheit ist, es gab mal Insel, wo es keine Freiheit gab. Jeder Grenzübergang war so eine Insel. Es gab Insel, wo es keine Freiheit gab. Und diese Insel haben sich langsam alle miteinander verbunden. Und jetzt gibt es Insel, wo es noch Freiheit gibt. Und zwischen diesen Inseln kommt immer mehr Platz. Und man ist also auf so einer Insel immer mehr eingesperrt, wenn man was machen will. Logistik, wenn es um Geld, wenn es um Personen, Transport, Information, Logistik, geht eigentlich nicht mehr oder nicht mehr sinnvoll, ohne dass man irgendwie gesehen wird, ohne dass man nachher auszuwerten ist. Und das ist schon schwierig. Das hängt davon ab, was man machen will. Das hängt davon ab, wie die Zukunft aussieht. Das hängt davon ab, wie undemokratisch es gerade in Holland oder in Deutschland oder wo auch immer wird.
Also ich glaube, wir sind uns alle darüber einig, dass es sozusagen in näherer Zukunft erstmal nicht zwingend besser wird. Was uns aber nicht der Verpflichtung enthebt, darüber nachzudenken, wie könnte es dann tatsächlich noch mal besser werden? Also was sind die Grundvoraussetzungen dafür, diese Dinge zurückzurollen? In den USA sehen wir gerade so die ersten zarten Anzeichen, wie sowas aussehen könnte. Dieser Skandal über irgendwie die NSA hat flächendeckend die Amerikaner abgehört. Da gibt es noch mehr offensichtlich. Also da kommen jetzt gerade so die ersten Gerüchte hoch, dass es da irgendwie noch größere Abhörprogramme gibt, die noch wesentlich schockierender sind. Und zwar so, dass sie noch nicht mal über den Kongress davon erzählen wollen. Aber das führt halt noch nicht zum Ziel. Aber darüber nachzudenken, was machen wir, wenn?
Das ändert ja nichts. Dass es jetzt skandalisiert wird im Nachhinein ändert ja nichts daran, dass die Daten erhoben worden sind und dass sie auch gespeichert werden.
Ja, aber man kann solche Sachen nutzen, um solche Programme zurückzurollen. Das heißt also, dass wir in der Lage sind, auf parlamentarischen und Öffentlichkeitswege vorbereitet zu sein für solche Ereignisse. Ich meine, wenn jede dieser Dinge geht schief, dann machen die Sachen, die sie nicht machen dürfen, also lassen die gesetzlichen Beschränkungen so geringfügig sein, wie sie seien, verstoßen tun sie immer dagegen. Es gibt tatsächlich solche Skandale, die werden nicht aufhören. Und wenn man jetzt gerade mal nur mal das Wort Abhörskandal in Google News eingibt, dann findet man irgendwie eine deutlich steigende Anzahl von Fällen so ringsum weltweit. Also überall passiert was. Griechenland, Bulgarien, Indien, Großbritannien.
Und es passiert ja auch nicht alles irgendwie komplett von alleine, sondern es gibt ja handelnde Personen, die man identifizieren kann. Also Parlamentarier, Ausschüsse beispielsweise. Und ich denke dort, ich meine, das ist zumindest was wir versuchen, was ich auch versuche, einfach dort eine Meinung zu hinterlassen, dort auch aufzuklären über bestimmte Zusammenhänge, über bestimmte Gefahren. Also oft ist es so, dass dann tatsächlich das Wissen um bestimmte Zusammenhänge vielleicht gar nicht da ist. Und ich glaube, es hilft auch, wenn einfach genügend Leute dort ihre Meinung zu den Dingen, bei den Leuten, die dafür verantwortlich sind, im Einzelnen dort hinterlassen und dort Bescheid sagen. Also dem werden sich auf Dauer, kann sich dem niemand entziehen.
Vielleicht solltest du den Argument, was wir gestern diskutiert hatten, dass vielleicht tatsächlich bürgerliche Freiheiten ein ökonomisch wertvoller Standortfaktor sind, noch mal ein bisschen ausbauen.
Ja, also mit großer Sicherheit ist es so, dass man braucht Freiheit, man braucht Schutz, Anonymität, um zum Beispiel eine schlecht funktionierende, kaputte oder korrupte Verwaltung abzuschaffen oder aufzudecken. Also um Dinge, die einfach schieflaufen, um die abzustellen, ist es unter Umständen nötig, dass Leute Schutz genießen durch Anonymität. Ich meine, das ist alles offensichtlich, es ist eigentlich auch bekannt. Das Problem ist, dass es zunehmend eben zum Lippenbekenntnis verkommt, aber man kann diese Dinge, diese Punkte, diese Zusammenhänge eigentlich nicht oft genug betonen, dass eine freie Gesellschaft einfach ein Wirtschaftsfaktor ist und dass auch Gerechtigkeit ein Wirtschaftsfaktor ist und dass Lebensqualität auch ein Wirtschaftsfaktor ist.
Was du aber durchgehend voraussetzen musst, ist, dass die Leute das überhaupt so wahrnehmen. Wenn ich Frank folge in seiner Einschätzung, dass es eine sehr komfortable Diktatur wird.
Ja genau, was stört euch eigentlich? Wir haben eine kleine, gutgehende Diktatur hier und das läuft ja alles. Ich glaube, um es mal wieder ein bisschen ernster No-Jokes auszudrücken, ein wichtiger Teil des Problems ist, dass das, womit wir hauptsächlich zu kämpfen haben, nämlich, dass sich Leute, die da eigentlich nichts verloren haben, unserer Daten, unserer zum Teil privaten und indemsten kleinen Bestandteile bemächtigen, dass das auf eine gespenstische Art und Weise abläuft, die so fühllos ist. Das ist alles so ein Abstraktum. Das ist alles irgendwie nicht zu spüren. Das tut niemandem weh, wenn mein Datenschatten sozusagen fortgenommen oder kopiert wird. Das erinnert auf eine kuriose Art und Weise an das, was in den 70er und 80er Jahren mit den Atomraketen passiert ist, die für den normalen Bürger genauso ein Abstraktum waren wie Daten. Das war was, was eine abstrakte Angst produziert hat. Irgendjemand hat mal gesagt, wenn Atomraketen Ohrenschmerzen verursachen würden, dann würde wesentlich mehr passieren. Also dann wären die wesentlich schneller verschwunden. Und mit den Daten ist das so ähnlich. Das heißt, ich glaube, dass eine Zukunftsperspektive, eine Möglichkeit, eine Notwendigkeit ist, etwas, was wir ohnehin im Club ständig tun und weiter tun sollten, ist, wir müssen das irgendwie spürbar machen. Das kannst du auf ganz viele verschiedene Arten machen. Das kannst du machen, indem du Geschichten darüber erzählst, ganz konkrete Geschichten. Das ist so, dass einen Teil dieser Aufgabe übernimmt das System selber. Das heißt, es werden immer mehr Menschen unmittelbar davon betroffen sein. Das heißt, wenn jetzt die Amerikaner merken, ups, ich bin auch abgehört worden, nicht nur die Bösen, anderen, dann rückt das einfach näher auf eine Art und Weise, wo man plötzlich spürt noch was. Plötzlich merkt man irgendwie so, da steht irgendwie ein netter Onkel vor meiner Tür und will mir Tante Alice verkaufen und der kommt auch wieder irgendwo her, der hat wieder irgendwelche Informationen, was ich jetzt habe oder vielleicht noch haben möchte und so weiter und so fort. Und der nervt und dauernd klingelt, rufen mich irgendwelche Computer an und teilt mir mit, dass ich irgendwas gewonnen habe und so weiter. Ich will das nicht, ich merke irgendwie so, die hocken schon in meinem Wohnzimmer und reden auf mich ein und wollen mir irgendwas verkaufen.
Diese Belästigung durch unerwünschte Anrufe ist sicherlich eins von den Dingen, wo es erstmal am klarsten wird. Oder der überquellende Briefkasten, der voll ist von unglaublichem Mist, der dann gleich in die Mülltonne wandert.
Trinkt jemand in dein innerstes Refugium ein, dort, wo er nichts verloren hat, und da kriegst du einfach so ein Hals. Und am fünften Mal reagierst du und es ist gut und gesund.
Chaosradio 110 liegt in den letzten Minuten. Rob, du bist immer noch am Telefon.
Ich bin immer noch am Telefon.
Hast du noch ein Schlusswort für uns?
Ich hab auch schon drüber nachgedacht und mir fällt nichts ein.
Ich dachte, du hättest vielleicht eine Empfehlung für ein Land, in das man wo man vielleicht hinaus wandern könnte, wo noch irgendwie Freiheit, Bürgerrechte und Demokratie in reinst Form herrschen.
Ich denke, das hängt davon ab, wofür man das genauso braucht. Wenn man nur so persönliche Sicherheit will, dann zieht man nach Neuseeland und geht auf dem Land und dann ist alles gut. Und dann kann man da alt werden, ohne von irgendjemandem belästigt zu werden. Nur dann hat man keinen Einfluss mehr. Und also Land hängt davon ab, was man damit will. Was will man? Will man noch Einfluss haben, dann muss man doch da sein, wo Kultur stattfindet und wo sie haben, passieren.
Tja, dann muss man tatsächlich damit leben, was passiert. Ich weiß nicht, aus wann uns, glaube ich, keine Lösung. Also letzten Endes, wenn wir uns in der Welt umgucken, sind die Probleme, die wir hier besprechen, zumindest zum gewissen Teil schon Luxusprobleme.
Das ist ja man auf sehr hohem Niveau.
Andersrum betrachtet ist es allerdings auch so, dass wenn wir es nicht schaffen, die europäischen Gesellschaften auf einem Niveau zu halten, dass die Menschenrechte noch halbwegs implementiert, dann fehlt für viele andere Länder auch einfach das Vorbild. Dann ist für viele andere, auch Befreiungsbewegungen oder Demokratiebewegungen, einfach ein sehr wesentliches Vorbild weg, wenn dieser Begriff von Freiheit zu einer hohlen Phrase vollkommt, mit der man nichts mehr anfangen kann, der bedienungs-sicherheitsbedenken geopfert wird. Insofern ist unsere Aufgabe schon tatsächlich hierbleiben und kämpfen, auch wenn es die nächsten paar Jahre echt lästig werden wird.
Dann machen wir noch eine schnelle Telefonrunde, weil ich glaube, die Frage lautet, wie kämpft man denn jetzt mal richtig? Also zumindest im Kleinen. Jens aus Ilmenau.
Eine Frage, und zwar noch zu Thor und Jack. Und zwar stellt sich mir die Frage, weil man ja nun durch diverse richterliche Entscheidungen, die nicht immer so ganz glücklich sind, wird man dann doch etwas verunsichert. Wie verhält sich das nun, wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel so ein Thor-Exit-Not ins Netz stellen will, um das Thor-Netz ein bisschen zu unterstützen? Ja, wenn die Staatsanwaltschaft ankommt und halt sagt, hier, hallo, von deinem Server aus wurde das und das gemacht und so und du sagst dann, ja, hier, ich hab halt Thor am Laufen und ich war das gar nicht. Also inwieweit, also wo steht man da rechtlich eigentlich? Also hier im Irk hat schon einer was von Exit-Policies erzählt. Kannst du da mal Näheres dazu sagen?
Nicht in der Sendung. Ich glaube, wir hatten demnächst sowieso noch eine Anonymizer-Sendung auf dem Zeiger.
Ich glaube, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Thema für einen der nächsten Chaosradio Express Folgen.
Also ich denke, wir sollten noch ein richtiges Chaosradio machen. Der CCC betreibt hier einen Anonymizer-Service, das heißt, wir haben auch schon gewisse Erfahrungen mit dergleichen juristischen Anfragen gesammelt. Und ich würde dann mal versuchen, dass wir die Leute, die sich darum gekümmert haben, ins Radio bekommen. Also entweder Chaosradio oder Chaosradio Express. Ich denke, da werden wir ein bisschen ausführlicher drauf eingehen. Ich kann das jetzt einfach aus dem Hut leider auch nicht beantworten.
Genau. Ihr könnt auch eure Fragen dazu uns einfach per Mail schon mal schicken. Das schadet gar nichts. Und gerne nehmen wir das auch per Telefon, also per Audio. Also könnt ihr selber aufzeichnen auf eurem Rechner oder auch unsere Feedback-Telefonnummer. Die sag ich jetzt ja auch gleich noch mal, ist die 018 01 99 33 22 99 55. Und wir nehmen das gerne gut auf.
Wie viele Telefonnummer waren das jetzt?
Das war eine Telefonnummer. Es waren mehrere Ziffern, soll ich sie noch mal sagen.
Ich glaube, es ist Telefon in der Webseite.
Na ja, du kannst auch 932 95 und das alles mal 2. Dann musst du allerdings noch die Wurzeln ziehen und sollen alle reinkommen.
Genau, sollen alle reinkommen.
Stefan aus Berlin, auch eine Frage.
Ja genau, und zwar zum Thema Datenschutz. Wenn die Leute mir im Internet erzielen, DRIBEL, DES oder AES, wären sicher, wie sicher sind die Algorithmen denn überhaupt?
Das hängt von der Implementierung ab. Und in der Regel lohnt es sich einfach mal zu gucken, wenn du ein bestimmtes Verschlüsselungsprodukt oder eine Verschlüsselungssoftware verwenden willst, vorher mal zu gucken, von wem sind die und gibt es schon irgendwelche Hinweise darauf, ob die Implementierungen tatsächlich sicher sind. Prinzipiell ist es so, dass man Kryptographie heutzutage so bauen kann, dass sie nach menschlichem Ermessen sicher ist. Garantie gibt es natürlich nie. Aber sag mal so, wenn du AES oder DRIBEL das verwendest, bist du zumindest schon mal so aus dem gröbsten raus. Je länger die keys, desto besser.
Irgendeine Softwareempfehlung, zum Beispiel TrueCrypt oder so, soll ja Freeware sein.
Ach, da gibt es so viele, ich würde jetzt keine speziell empfehlen können.
Hängt auch ganz davon ab, was du verschlüsseln willst.
Ob ich eine Plattform habe?
Ja, okay, ich habe gleich schon mal das nächste Thema notiert. Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen.
Naja, das kann man ja vielleicht mit der Anonymizer-Geschichte auch zusammenschmeißen. Aber das sind ja nur wirklich auch Mittel für Otto Normal User, die mit einem einfachen Klick machen kann. Sonst wäre das die Frage, wie kämpfen wir?
So mal so Sicherheit und Unimität im Netz so als...
Genau, dieses Thema hier ist ja jetzt deutlich mehr die Meta-Ebene.
Das Meta-Thema.
Ja, das Meta-Thema.
Stefan, vielen Dank. Und den letzten noch mal, Sven aus Kiel.
Auch schon einen Bleistift, Wähler?
Ja, ich habe einen Bleistift gehabt, ja. Nee, das ist echt schwer. Man wartet so lange in der Leitung und macht sich irgendwie so viel Gedanken.
Ja, du hast jetzt nur noch 30 Sekunden.
Ja, scheiße, was sage ich denn jetzt?
Schreibt eine Mail oder plappert uns auf den Anrufbeantworter.
Ich wollte nur mal fragen, wenn ihr sagt, diese ewige Liste, und einerseits ist es gut, irgendwie diese Blogs zu machen, um seine eigenen Magen zu verteilen. Was ist denn jetzt besser, einen Blog zu machen oder lieber die Schnur zu zeigen?
Am besten ist ein anonymes Blog zu machen, weil dann kannst du die Schnur zu aufmachen, ohne dabei irgendwie einen Schaden zu riskieren.
So sieht es aus.
Okay, weil der Frau gewollt, ich sage, wenn sie irgendwie so kritisch ist, dann soll sie doch mal einen Blog machen.
Genau, wenn ihr ein anonymes Weblog haben wollt, dann sollte mal auf invisiblog.com schauen.
Ja gut, das war ein Tipp.
Da gibt es die Möglichkeit, das wirklich anonymen zu machen, das ist kroptografisch abgesichert.
invisiblog.com. Dann zieht Stackenbloch in deinen um. Ha, kann ich endlich mal vom Leder ziehen?
Du bist das, dein Blog ist das.
Nein, ich bin das nicht.
Entschuldigung.
Der Trend geht zum Zweitblog.
Du hast während der Sendung gebloggt.
Das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Darfst du das überhaupt?
Bloggen während der Sendung? Blogzwang, genau. Ich bin Zwangsblogger.
Wir gründen die anonymen Blogger. Blogger Anonymous. Ich habe gebloggt. Oh Gott, nie wieder.
Können wir vorne auf den Stern drauf. Paragraf 200, irgendwas. Ich habe gebloggt. Gehen wir jetzt nach Hause?
Ja, nochmal vielen Dank an den Hörern.
Das war Chaosradio 101, Fighting the War, das Thema der Sendung. Der Kampf um die Freiheit.
Um die Freiheit.
Der Kampf um die Freiheit war das Thema auf einer Metaebene. Mit welchen Mitteln, also mit welchen Waffen gekämpft werden kann, wird eines der nächsten Chaosradios hoffentlich erörtern.
Genau. Wer eine Aufzeichnung von dieser Sendung haben will und überhaupt kein Chaosradio verpassen möchte, der sollte vielleicht den Chaosradio als Podcast abonnieren. Mit der passenden Software. Das findet ihr auf chaosradio.de die Information, wie ihr das machen könnt. Und dann rauscht jede Aufzeichnung von Chaosradio, Chaosradio Express und zusätzlich auch noch ein paar lustigen Dokumenten und Filmchen, die sonst immer noch uns interessant erscheinen, direkt auf euren Computer, ohne dass ihr da was tun müsst.
Also um genau zu sein, ist es immer so viel, dass man eigentlich den gesamten Tag schon damit zubringen kann.
Ansonsten haben wir noch die Sachen, die aus dem Chaosradio viel rausfallen.
Das 24-Stunden-Entertainment.
Außerdem haben wir noch unser Magazin die Datenschleuder, wo dieses Thema auch eigentlich, denke ich mal, auch in den nächsten Ausgaben noch diskutiert werden wird. Irgendwie gibt es von WBCC-CDE irgendwo einen Link auf die Datenschleuder, wie man die abonnieren kann. Lohnt sich immer. Und das kleines Heftchen. Jetzt auch zu sehen mit Randes Ministerpräsidenten, was war es? Mit wem hatten wir ein Foto? Mit dem sächsischen Ministerpräsidenten. Ich glaube, wir haben als Werbung verwendet.
Leider ein bisschen unscharf.
Ich beende das jetzt hier, denn der Kollege Martin Petersdorf steht schon in den Startlöchern für den Nightflight. Das war Chaosradio 1 und 10. Mit dabei waren Frank, der Peter Glaser, der Pavel, der Tim, die Knöpfe gedrückt hat, Holger Klein, der spricht hier auch gerade noch.
Und Rob nicht vergessen.
Entschuldige, Rob, du bist immer noch da, ne?
Ich bin immer noch da.
Hör mal, bleibt dran, wir melden uns morgen.
Danke Rob und tschüss. Was wollte ich sagen? Genau, das Chaosradio, den Blumen mit dem Chaos Computer Club, gibt es immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, außer im Dezember. Aber das tut jetzt nicht zur Sache, denn das nächste Chaosradio ist im März. Und zwar ist es der 29. März, an dem es Chaosradio 111 geben wird.
Rob hat auch während der Sendung geblockt. Echt?
Das kriegt aus.
Was hat der denn geblockt? Ich hab ja so Boulevardthemen gehabt.
Während der Sendung geblockt ist es offensichtlich nicht.
Rob äußert sich eher zum Thema.
Ah ja, ich nicht so. Danke, dass ihr hier wart, Jungs. Und danke für die Aufmerksamkeit, Höhrende. Fünf Minuten nach Einsamers. Das war Chaos Computer Blue Moon.